Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Oh, ich muss meine Zeit entwirren, Sekunde, Leute.
So, besser.
Jetzt kann ich mich wenigstens weiter als 15 cm von meinem Anschluss wegbewegen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das überhaupt möglich ist.
Wie kann sich innerhalb von 1,5 bis 2 Monaten, vielleicht sogar weniger, 2 bis 4 Wochen das Headset Kabel so verknoten,
dass es quasi nur noch ein Drittel lang ist vom ursprünglichen Kabel.
Wie geht das? Ich knote das ja nicht absichtlich.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Und ich stelle gerade fest, ich habe meinen Akkuschrauber auf dem Drucker neben mir liegen.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum. Bin mir nicht so sicher, warum ich den Akkuschrauber hier liegen habe, aber okay.
Einfach random mit dem zwölflichen Akkuschrauber. Na, warum nicht? Brauchen wir ihn immer mal wieder.
Schon wieder früh auf der Stream. Ja, weil der Stellzoar subscribt. 23 Monate Massive-Subscription. Richtig pock.
Weil ich muss wieder MMO kreiten später. Leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich spiele ja gerade wieder ein bisschen Dark Age of Camelot auf dem Free-Shot.
Und ich habe seit Server-Release jeden Tag mindestens 5 Stunden plus gespielt oder so.
Richtig gestört. Free-Shot ist wahrscheinlich innerhalb von einem halben Jahr tot und der Progress weg oder so.
Warum nicht? Kreiselgrind. Ja, noch nicht mal richtig Kreiselgrind. PvP-Grind.
Wir haben mittlerweile schon so ungefähr 6-8 feste Leute, die immer mitspielen abends.
Die Gruppen in Dark sind ja 8er-Gruppen. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach, weil du brauchst mindestens 2 Heiler,
du brauchst mindestens eine Speed-Klasse, du brauchst mindestens eine CC-Klasse und du brauchst AE-Damage für mehr RPs.
Und wir Kreiselgrinden so hart mittlerweile, dass wir eigentlich jeden Tag top im Scoreboard sind für Kills, für Punkte, für Heilung, für Deathblow, für alles.
So hart der Kreiselgrind ist am Start.
Weil ich nicht mit World of Warcraft aufgewachsen bin in dem Fall.
Viele spielen wahrscheinlich immer noch gerne das erste MMORPG, was sie je gespielt haben. Das andere kann ich mir auch die ganze RuneScape-Leute nicht erklären.
Oder die ganzen FA-Quest-Classic-Leute. Wobei ohne Scheiß PvP Dark Age of Candle ist das beste Spiel, was es gibt.
Ich bin am überlegen, ob ich das nicht mal eine Runde streame. Ich weiß, es werden sich wahrscheinlich jetzt keine 2, 3, 400 Leute angucken.
Aber ich glaube, dass PvP ist, gerade weil wir BG spielen mit irgendwie 100 Leuten plus, eigentlich ganz lustig zu gucken.
Also kann ich mir vorstellen, ich weiß es nicht. Gestern gab es halt so die krassesten Fights aller Zeiten.
Irgendwie halbe Stunde lang 100 vs. 100 vs. 100. Und wir haben es irgendwie am Ende gewonnen.
Mit C hinten dran, nicht mit K.
Ich spiele hier auf dem Freeshark. Wie viele POE-Kraisel-Kreine geschaut haben? Keine Ahnung, 100 oder so.
Ich spiele auf dem Freeshark. Aktuell sind ungefähr 1.000 Leute an. Abends sind so 2.300, 2.400 Leute an.
Und es ist halt sehr entschlackt. Also das ganze PvE, Equipen und Leveln geht deutlich angenehmer als auf Live damals.
Und das PvP ist genau das gleiche.
Also kannst du hier innerhalb von 2, 3 Tagen eigentlich einen Char machen und Equipen.
Wohingegen du auf Live irgendwie 2 Monate Leveln hast. Zur damaligen Zeit.
Aber MMO-Drama, Leute. Der MMO-Drama ist das Beste.
Ich lache mich jedes Mal kaputt, wie sehr sich eine Horde 35 plusjähriger, wozu ich auch gehöre,
aber ich steige mich da nicht so rein, so krass in das Game reinsteigern können, dass sie so ausflippen wegen jedem Scheiß.
Das ist irgendwie lustig.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, dass die Leute, wenn sie Sachen spielen, was sie früher gespielt haben, wo sie noch jünger waren,
dass sie in ihrem Kopf dann wieder zurückverfallen in das, was sie früher gemacht haben.
Oh, mein Mikro stimmt nicht. Teams hat wieder am Mikro rumgestellt.
Ja, so ist es besser.
Also sprich, wenn die Leute damals übelste Spaß im Ingame waren und heute sich eigentlich ganz normal verhalten im normalen Leben.
Und wenn sie dann wieder das Spiel spielen, was sie damals gespielt haben, wo sie sich wie Ultraspasten im Ingame verhalten haben,
dann verhalten sie sich heute wieder so.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendeine Erklärung für dieses Phänomen gibt.
Ja, ja. Eichensteinei für den Sub.
Ist denn IT technisch diese Woche? Gab es irgendwas Spannendes bei Heise oder so?
Open Source Gipfel. Nur offene Technologie ist nachhaltig.
Ok, kann man einfach mal so in den Raum stellen.
Covid früher ansteckend als gedacht.
Ob das jetzt nur früh oder noch früh ansteckend ist, ist mir eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Was sie vor dem Kauf wissen sollen.
Ja, soll ich euch mal was sagen, was das Beste ist, was man wissen muss vor dem Kauf eines Elektroautos?
Hier habt ihr es zuerst gehört. Nee, Schwachsinn. Wahrscheinlich habt ihr es hier nicht zuerst gehört.
Behaltet einfach euer altes Auto, weil nichts ist umweltschonender und nachhaltig,
als den alten Scheiß weiter zu benutzen, bis er endlich endgültig kaputt ist.
Kauft euch einfach kein neues Auto, wenn ihr nicht ein neues Auto braucht.
Ist nachweislich so.
Ist Marcel Davis, ja, Marcel Davis kommt bestimmt als Edge-Lord hier in den Chat. Das ganz mit Sicherheit.
Glaub ich dir sofort.
Aber ansonsten gab es irgendwie diese Woche nicht so viel Spannendes.
Hacker attackiert Nordkoreas Internet.
Na, da gibt es ja auch nicht viel zu attackieren, oder?
Da ist wahrscheinlich nicht viel, was du kaputt machen kannst.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, Hacker haben auch das Internet in Andorra, also DDoSer, Minecraft DDoSer,
haben das Internet in Andorra lahmgelegt, weil irgendein komisches Minecraft-Turnier war.
Ok, es gab diese Woche wohl nicht so viel Spannendes.
Na dann.
Nein, nein, nein. Zwei Musiksagen gleichzeitig brauchen wir nicht.
So, YouTube, was empfiehlst du uns?
Nee, das ist das falsche Fenster.
Das ist das richtige Fenster, oder?
Sekunde, ich bin verwirrt. Was ist das richtige Fenster?
Das ist das falsche Fenster?
Ich glaube, das ist das richtige Fenster.
Ach guck mal, mein eigenes Video wird empfohlen.
Aber wir gucken jetzt nicht.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und eigentlich wollte ich es gut sein lassen, was Battlefield 2042 betrifft.
Aber was soll ich machen?
Ich muss das Ganze und die Legen...
Legen mit E, egal.
Es ist ziemlich gut zu erkennen, was man sagt mittlerweile.
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch irgendjemand daran wie grottenschlecht dieses Transcript ursprünglich auf YouTube war.
Mittlerweile ist das ziemlich gut und macht, würde man sagen, in 90% der Fällen das Richtige.
Also, huge IQ AI im Hintergrund am Start wieder.
Huge IQ haben wahrscheinlich die Programmierer.
Ja, mein eigenes Video ist am Start.
Sehr schön.
Was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn sonst noch?
Update soon, ja vor drei Wochen.
Lustig, oder?
Vor drei Wochen gibt es ein Video.
Battlefield will get updates soon.
Und jetzt weiß man, bis zum Sommer kommt nichts mehr.
Okay, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Sie haben mir Update, was jetzt kommen sollte, demnächst auf März verschoben.
Aber das wird nur Kleinigkeiten fixen.
Und das meiste bleibt bis Sommer.
Das ist so schlecht, so schlecht.
Was empfiehlt uns denn sonst YouTube?
Was?
Reality Star verkauft Fürze.
Also mich wundern heutzutage nicht mehr.
Ich meine, wenn Gamer Girl Badewasser verkauft wird,
wo am Ende gar kein Gamer Girl drin war,
also das Gamer Girl Badewasser, was verkauft wurde,
war ja noch nicht mal Gamer Girl Badewasser.
Es gibt ja Leute, die haben das analysiert und festgestellt,
da sind keine Hautschuppen drin und dementsprechend
kann es kein Gamer Girl Badewasser sein.
Wundert mich nicht, dass man auch Fürze verkaufen kann.
Warum nicht?
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich das weiß, aber
habe ich so mitgekriegt.
Scammed, ja, aber ganz ehrlich, wer Gamer Girl Badewasser
wirklich kauft, der möchte eigentlich gescampt werden.
Ich frage mich ganz im Ernst, was machen die denn eigentlich
dann damit, wenn sie sich das gekauft haben?
Also manche Sachen kannst du dir hinstellen und angucken,
die sehen nicht aus.
Aber was machst du mit einem Pot Gamer Girl Badewasser?
Nee, trinken kannst du Badewasser nicht, da musst du,
da ist ja Seife und so drin.
Ich verkaufe Kekse, ja, du kannst jetzt auf YouTube,
Leute, ihr könnt jetzt auf YouTube, wenn ihr zu viel Geld
übrig habt, ihr könnt jetzt auf YouTube joinen,
was jetzt hier nicht geht, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Ihr könnt Channelmember werden und dann bekommt ihr,
glaube ich, mittlerweile acht Kekse-Emoals, die sind
dann so in der Richtung aus.
Guck, sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Ich kann jetzt...
Oh, OmegaLulWoop at Gmail.
Ja, genau, damit will ich mich jetzt...
Ach so.
Was weiß ich denn, was ich da für ein Passwort hatte?
Das war irgendein Fake-Account, den wir hier mal im Stream
gemacht haben.
Da weiß ich doch beim besten Willen das Passwort jetzt
nicht mehr.
OmegaLulWoop.
Okay.
Dann nicht.
Aber da gibt es dann solche Poggers-Kekse und
Hacker-Man-Kekse, also ein Teil von dem, was es hier
auf Twitch auch gibt.
Aber YouTube-Memberships sind jetzt auch nicht
der weisheitsletzter Schluss irgendwie, wie YouTube
das gebaut hat zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Emoals skalieren beispielsweise in Firefox nicht richtig.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Ich hoffe, das kriegen sie noch hin.
So, und ansonsten ist, glaube ich, nicht so viel
Spannendes in den Empfehlungen drin.
Oh, ja.
Two years later.
Google Stadia.
Braucht man das wirklich?
Aber das Video habe ich schon aufgemacht.
Das gucken wir uns nachher mal an.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das machen wir nicht.
Wir machen, wenn schon, also wir verkaufen keine Kekse.
Wir müssen Keks-NFTs machen, wenn schon.
Wir müssen mit der Zeit gehen.
Wo man natürlich nicht die Rechte an irgendeinem
Video bekommt, sondern einfach nur einen Link darauf,
was jeder andere auch benutzen kann.
Weil es werden ja keinerlei NFTs wirklich in der
Blockchain gespeichert, was ja schwachsinnig ist.
Also egal, ich verstehe diesen ganzen NFT-Trend nicht.
Na doch, doch, ich verstehe ihn mittlerweile.
Ganz viele Leute wittern da irgendwie die schnelle
große Kohle, ohne eigentlich nur einen Funken dessen
verstanden zu haben, was da eigentlich gehandelt wird.
NTFS schmeckt nicht, das stimmt.
Wir machen NEX.
Was sind denn NEX?
Non-Eatable Keks?
Ah, dachte ich mir, ja.
Programmersprachen 2022.
Oh, da haben wir uns schon so viele Videos zu angeguckt.
Homeserver-Entscheidung.
Warum kriege ich denn so viele Videos von mir selbst empfohlen?
Als möchte YouTube sagen, der Max macht gescheite Videos.
Guck dir das mal an.
Aber das kann ja nicht sein.
Smart-Apartment-Tour.
Das ist ganz schön lang.
Okay, das gucken wir uns am Ende.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich gucke mir bestimmt keine Apple HomeKit Smart-Home-Tour an.
Das werde ich mir eh nicht geben.
Self-hosting on your home server.
Cloudflare plus Engine X-Manager.
Easy SSL Setup.
Das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Moment.
Ist das nicht der Typ mit fünf Kompanie des Clusters daheim,
der sich fragt, warum er die hat?
Leute, ich habe mir jetzt,
weil ihr das auch schon öfters erwähnt habt im Stream,
ich habe mir jetzt versucht, Unraid zu installieren,
weil ich mir das mal angucken wollte in einer VM.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, das machen wir dann im nächsten Stream zusammen,
weil das erste, was ich festgestellt habe, ist,
dass Unraid nicht mal eine ISO hat,
um es einfach in einer VM installieren zu können.
Die haben sich gedacht, ISO ist zu oldschool, machen wir nicht.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, ja gut, dann installiere ich es erstmal nicht
und wir gucken uns im Stream zusammen an, wie das funktioniert.
So, also, wir lassen uns jetzt eine Runde gibaten von LevelCap,
weil wir uns immer von LevelCap gibaten lassen am Anfang des Streams.
ISO Legacy, so wie Scoreboards.
Scoreboards und ISOs ist quasi so auf einem Level.
Kannst du eine Steckdoseleiste empfehlen, die steuerbar ist?
Das Problem dabei ist, sowas zu empfehlen.
Wenn ich dir heute das empfehle, was ich als letztes geflasht habe,
kann es schon wieder sein, dass es nicht mehr flashtbar ist.
Also die letzte Steckdosenleiste, die ich mir gekauft habe,
war eine Tuya Steckdosenleiste, die Hammer reprandet hat.
Hammer, Hammer Hammer, smart.
Die da.
Die habe ich mir zuletzt gekauft, nicht weil ich ein Hammer-Fan bin,
sondern weil es exakt diese Steckdosenleiste
von bestimmt 30 verschiedenen Herstellern gibt.
Und ich schon einige davon gekauft habe, weil man die noch flaschen kann.
Die Sache ist die, keine Ahnung, ob das aktuell noch so ist.
Wir können ja mal in die Ratings gucken.
Was genau hat dieses Bild hier mit der Steckdosenleiste zu tun?
Strom sparen leicht gemacht.
Damit spart man sicherlich ganz viel Strom.
Das motortaugliche Steckdosenleiste, sehr gut.
Dezember, Tasmota noch immer möglich.
Stand 13. Dezember 2021.
Guck mal, 11. Januar, Tasmotanutzer.
Ja, also hier hast du vielleicht noch ganz gute Chancen, dass die funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal, reviews most recent, ob da einer was schreibt.
Guck mal, Tasmota 26.
Ich habe davon auch gleich irgendwie einen Fünferpack bestellt
und davor noch einen zum Testen.
Ich habe sechs Stück davon bestellt, weil ich für die nächsten Jahre
meine Steckdosenleisten-Needs decken musste.
Bei denen ist bei mir eine am USB-Part in Rauch aufgegangen.
Bei einer anderen gehen die USB-Port.
Der USB-Port ist in Rauch aufgegangen, okay.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Also ich habe davon im Keller eine liegen schon eine ganze Weile.
Ich habe hier oben eine stehen.
Also ich hatte da jetzt auch keine Probleme mit.
Naja.
Aber die hat doch ein CE-Zeichen.
Da kann man sich doch bei China-Geräten drauf verlassen, ist doch kein Problem.
Kann man die auch über den Browser steuern?
Ja, also noch mal ganz kurz gesagt, weil es immer gefragt wird, die Vorteile,
oh fuck, ich finde meinen Chat nicht mehr.
Die Vorteile, es zu flashen, sind vielleicht so für den Außenstehenden
nicht sofort ersichtlich, aber du brauchst keine China-Chinesen-Cloud,
dass dein Gerät funktioniert.
Das heißt, du brauchst doch gar kein Internetzugang,
Du brauchst nicht die offizielle App, dass dein Gerät funktioniert.
Du kannst es einfacher einbinden in jede x-beliebige Heimautomatisierung,
nicht so wie das Originale.
Du hast keine China-Chinesen-Firmware drauf, wo du nicht weißt,
was sie in deinem WLAN macht.
Du hast ein Webinterface zum Steuern anstatt eine App.
Ja, ich glaube, das war es so im Großen und Ganzen.
Lidl hat auch welche, dann aber ZigBee mit Home Assistant.
Ernsthaft? Lidl steckt... da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Zeig mal, Lidl Steckdosenleisten.
Und dann muss ich nach... Alter, was ist das denn?
Ich glaube, das ist Favorit für die hässlichste Steckdosenleiste,
die ich je gesehen habe.
So, welche Steckdosenleiste soll ich nach ZigBee suchen?
Welche Soundboard hast du eigentlich?
Äh, das hier.
Das habe ich selbst programmiert.
Das hat keinen Namen.
Das kann GIFs, Bilder, MP4s, GIFs plus Sound.
GIFs plus Sound verwende ich tatsächlich relativ wenig.
GIFs plus Sounds habe ich, glaube ich, nur den hier.
Oder... Ach nee, NICE haben wir auch noch.
Und um die Leute im Home Office zu triggern, habe ich den hier.
Da machen jetzt alle gerade den da, wenn sie das hören.
Was? Silverdings Smart Home. Okay, zeig her.
Das ist ZigBee... Okay.
Okay. Die hat nur drei? Die hat nur drei? Okay.
Das ist doch auch nur China-Chinesen-Reprint, oder?
Das ist garantiert China-Chinesen-Reprint.
Ja, auch die allein schon... Allein schon hier... Okay. Okay. Jetzt... Jetzt erklärt mir mal den Sinn davon, eine Remote Schaltbare Steckdosenleiste zu haben.
Die ich dann wiederum in eine Remote Schaltbare Steckdosenleiste in die Steckdosenleiste schalten kann.
Und dann kann die Leute auch mal mit dem Treffer des Steckdosenleistes einsteigen.
zu haben die ich dann wiederum in eine remote schaltbare steckdosen leiste in die steckdose stecke
warum gut sie wollen ihre produkte platzieren
doppelt hält besser wenn die anfängt zu brennen kannst du damit ausschalten oder wie
ich bin ich bin geneigt dazu mir das zu installieren nicht zu inszenen zu kaufen um auszuprobieren ob das
funktioniert warum gibt es die hier zweimal
das doch die gleiche oder warum gibt es die zweimal
i o broker usb port sind nicht steuerbar das ist eigentlich normal hauptsache der
usb port an sich also sehr vierer block ist ein ausschaltbar
man kann anscheinend jede einzel schalten ja leute ich glaube ich bestelle mir da einfach mal was
von das ist doch genau das gleiche oder ist das jetzt warum gibt es das zweimal
ja ich bin fast geneigt dazu das einfach mal auszuprobieren wie gut sich das integrieren
das ich speichere mir das mal kurz hier die silver crest das ist so ein typischer china
china chinesen name wobei silver crest geht noch vom namen her die meisten das da kann man sich
irgendwie noch ein bisschen was darunter vorstellen aber die meisten china produkte die heißen ja oder
oder die haben die haben so ganz komische namen zum beispiel suchen wir mal nach alexa steckdosen
leister so tapotet aber ist den system milfra milfra so ja das sind so typische das sind so
typische china china chinesen dinger vom namen her u smart joe mo joe mo das sind so die typischen
china namen da weißt du gleich an teller das sind so die typischen random generated china
produktnamen eigentlich alles das gleiche unten drunter aber am ende verkaufen sie das alles
immer unter rief was sie schenken jungen jungen joe mo aber u smart mir aus das ist alles china
chinesen zeug so gut ich probiere das mal aus wie gut das funktioniert in home assistant aber
amazon ist mittlerweile zum zweiten aliexpress gewonnen ja gut aber marketplace gibt es auch
schon lang aliexpress ist ja nur marketplace das ist recht wild was die implementierung von
sich nicht sehr standard konform ok also lang das so lang das das können wir jetzt gerade mal
nachgucken ob das so ported wird ich blick bei meinen tabs nicht mehr durch schauen wir doch mal
sich b2 mq tt sondern schauen wir mal ob das supportet die weißes search silver crest
nein selber crest ganz bei was was sehe ich was ist das was sehe ich da bodenfeuchtigkeit
oder das ist eine steckdose für den garten oder eine wasserdichte steckdose für den garten das
müsste sein hier ja ja scheint zu funktionieren so lange das sich b2 mq tt unterstützt ist mir
das egal ob das sich b standard da gut oder schlecht oder wie auch immer gebaut ist man die
handa schon drum herum programmiert ja sollte sich theoretisch einfach peeren lassen ich
probiere das aus ich bestell mir eine dann ist auf jeden fall eine günstigere alternative und
es funktioniert immer noch weil bei den anderen ist ja mit tuja konvert immer wird immer immer
schwieriger eigentlich kaum noch möglich hey max mein vater ist poolbauer als das quasi der
erste poolbauer den ich auch nur um zwei ecken kenne aber immerhin ich hatte noch nie kontakt
mit einem poolbauer aber ok mein vater ist poolbauer und hatte ich ich wusste gar nicht
dass es das noch gibt ich dachte immer du baust ja gut irgendjemand muss ja beauftragen wenn
ein pool haben willst irgendjemand muss das machen ok und hatte die idee dass sie in ihrem geschäft
anbieten sowas wie temperatur und ph wird auf eine app ins handy ausgeben so dass ich kenne
mich abentwicklung oder so nur hast du eine die immer das muss ja weißt du was ich empfehlen
würde ok aus zwei sachen also aus meiner sicht oder aus business stonks sicht weil meine sicht
ist nicht unbedingt business stonksicht weißt was ich anbieten würde ich würde irgendwas anbieten
was offene schnittstellen hat und nicht mich zwingt eine app zu verwenden vom hersteller die
da vielleicht gar nicht richtig supportet oder und es ist die business stonksicht ihr nehmt
irgendwas fertiges und rebrandet das aber besser wäre es wahrscheinlich ihr bietet irgendwelche
sachen an die ihr quasi dann gleich mit dem pool einbaut das ist dann halt auch von der
stromversorgung und sowas ordentlich installiert ist wenn die leute sich das selbst einbauen
dann was sie sich irgendwie kurzschluss oder sonst was und dass die sachen halt übertragen
kann per wifi an was weiß ich mqtt per http abrufbar dass du dann diese sensoren integrieren
kannst easy in jede x beliebige heimautomatisierungslösung ja weil wenn du sensoren hast die du abfragen
kannst per http oder per per mqtt oder sonst was dann kannst du die auch in jeder x beliebigen
handy app einbinden die das abfragen kann also ihr müsstet gar keine eigene app programmieren
ihr könntet den sensor anbieten und da könnt ihr den leuten beispielsweise zwei drei apps
empfehlen mit der man sich die sache anzeigen lassen kann und zusätzlich ist der vorteil
man könnte diese sensoren auch noch easy in jegliche heimautomatisierungen einbauen
ja dann müsstet ihr halten soweit plan davon haben wie man microcontroller programmiert
oder ihr kauft euch irgendwas fertiges ihr müsstet quasi in den esp 32 bauen mit mit
sensoren dran der mqtt und hat und wifi und alles macht also ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so easy müsst ja dann auch irgendwas bauen wobei das bauen wahrscheinlich bei euch weniger
das problem wer ihr könntet es ja dann sind sind nicht in die elektronik vom pool integrieren
dass es nicht nass wird dass es keinen kurzschluss bekommt dass der sen das das halt ein gescheiter
sensor ist der auch das ordentliche mist den sensor der nicht nach zwei jahren kaputt geht
ja ich habe keine ahnung ob es einen vernünftigen sensor explizit für den esp gibt aber es
gibt sicherlich vernünftige ph sensoren die man anschließen kann und sei es nur über
irgendeinen analog digital konverter garantiert ansonsten beauftragt ihr einfach mich wir
programmieren das im stream und ich schreibe euch dann eine rechnung dann habe ich stream
content und geld verdient damit gibt ja mittlerweile auch manage next clouds durch deutscher anbieter
server stehen wohl an in deutschland wird es so was ganz ehrlich ganz ehrlich ich mag
nicht das mag vielleicht ok ich denke aus business enterprise sicht ergibt es sinn
wenn man das machen muss in deutschland anbieten ok aber ganz ehrlich also wenn ich mein zeug
in die cloud legen würde dann eh nur verschlüsselt auch in deutschland und dementsprechend könnte
ich es auch auf google drive oder next cloud legen ja es wäre halt sinnvoll was zu bauen
was auch wirklich eine weile hält aber sag mal so so ein produkt entwickeln von idee bis
das dann auch wirklich funktionieren hält das ist könnte ich stelle ich mir vor ein
bisschen langwierige geschichte man muss das muss das ordentlich testen dann muss man hoffen
dass man nicht verbockt hat
na gut gucken wir mal ein paar videos und ich muss eben bei bombon lutschen weil sonst
kriege ich mir so ein trockenen hals ich merke schon und ihr habt mich immer noch nicht dran
erinnert dass ich halt dass ich mich hightraten soll sack muss mich hightraten also doch doch
doch das ist definitiv ein vorteil und wenn es so ein rechtlicher vorteil ist ob es unterm
strichen großen unterschied macht weiß ich nicht aber rechtlich ist es auf jeden fall
ein vorteil mark ldm danke für den sub hey max ich bin seit zwei monaten dabei mir das
peisen programmieren beizubringen ich mache noch mal kurz musik an ich dachte wir gucken
jetzt videos aber wir gucken keine videos wir gucken erst noch mal kurz comments ich blicke
nicht mehr durch hilfe wo so viel chat chat und tabs und guckt euch mal wie viele tabs
hier offen sind also hey max ich bin seit zwei monaten bei mir das mir das peisen programmieren
beizubringen mein ziel ist es später noch html und css zu lernen um in der frontend
tätig zu sein was ist so deine erfahrung damit für die chance selbst beigebracht ich
ganz im ernst die meisten programmierer sind selbst beigebracht ja es gibt welche die
am informatik studiert und die haben ein bisschen algorithmen in java und sonst was gelernt aber
so die praktischen dinge die lernste eigentlich nur durch try and error und erfahrung und
im prinzip so ziemlich jeder programmierer den ich kenne hat da hat da irgendwann mal
aus eigenem interesse daran angefangen zumindest die guten ja noch das was so eine ausbildung
beigebracht kriegst reicht nicht du musst dich selbst damit beschäftigen das heißt
unter dem strich sind eigentlich alle programmierer selbst beigebracht die frage ist nur wie viel
praktische erfahrung du am endeffekt hast also es ist schon ein unterschied ob man daheim
sitzt und irgendwie an seinem ein mann github projekt bastelt oder ob man vielleicht noch
mit ein paar andere leuten zusammen was programmiert das ist schon ein unterschied und wenn da
noch irgendwelche komischen manager und product owner und stonks leute dabei kommen kommt
dann am ende was anderes raus als man sich ursprünglich gedacht hat aber du hast wenn
du wenn du was kannst hast du gute chancen wird mir keine gedanken zu machen ansonsten
wenn du ins front end willst wäre es sinnvoll mit java script html und css anzufangen und
python erstmal links liegen zu lassen weil python ist zwar eine wunderbare einsteiger
sprache und ver verwendet der ein oder andere vielleicht auch für web backends wobei ich
weiß es gibt es gibt viele coole sachen aber mir fällt jetzt fällt euch irgendwie ein
größeres unternehmen ein was heißen ist youtube nicht ist youtube nicht nicht passend beckent
war da nicht irgendwas weiß youtube oder war youtube nicht sogar die google searches garantiert
nicht passen im back end ja gut keine ahnung ich bilde mir ein youtube war youtube nicht
passen ich keine ahnung wow ah kirby musik hilfe nicht so laut aber so verstehe ok das
stanz echt youtube ok back end server seit cc plus plus python pvp java go krasse mischung
jahu alter warum hat jahu bitteschön so viele aufrufe immer noch warum ist jahu immer noch
so krass auf überlegt euch mal jahu hat ein drittel der aufruf zahlen von youtube jahu
ich habe jahu glaube ich seit 20 jahren nicht mehr verwendet ok etsy ich weiß nicht mehr
was etsy ist das ist ja mehr als amazon bitter bing oh man weiß ich nicht was es ist echt
nicht so wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich da drauf gekommen ja also ich denke du hast gute chancen
wenn du was kannst fertig denkst du es macht sinn so ein senso ein raspberry pi zu hängen
oder gibt es sensoren die von alleine an htp übertragen können oder die von alleine auf
htp übertragen können so nee nee nee also ich würde es nicht an raspberry pi hängen
raspberry pi ist deutlich wartungsintensiver als so ein microcontroller und eigentlich
nah extrem krasse overkill für zwei sensoren du musst sowas hier nehmen du musst so ein
controller hier nehmen zum beispiel haben wir hier im stream ja auch schon öfters programmiert
so einen controller nehmen kannst du sogar mit arduino programmieren und da hängst du
den sensor dran und dann musst du halt selbst dafür sorgen dass das über htp und mqtt funktioniert
was kein großer akt ist da gibt es libraries für also raspberry pi ist glaube ich ein
bisschen overkill für einen für einen sensor in dem pool ich meine du kannst einen raspberry
pi machen dann hast du den vorteil du kannst du hast halt deutlich mehr ressourcen als
auf so eine microcontroller halten die auch länger als die sd karten in raspberry pi
ja die halten eigentlich auf unbestimmte zeit wenn du die innerhalb ihrer specs betreibst
also mir ist glaube ich ein bisschen insgesamt bisher bestimmt eine handvoll esp ist kaputt
gegangen aber immer nur weil ich mist gebaut habe zu viel spannung oder sowas
der vorteil von einem raspberry pi in dem fall für so eine pool sensor wäre halt wenn
du dich sagen wir mal auskennst jetzt mit pap und sowas und du dann ein webinterface
für bauen willst das kannst du auf raspberry pi ein bisschen einfacher machen weil du
es halt mit den üblichen programmier sprachen und den üblichen frameworks und halt eine
vollständige linux umgebung hast das macht ein bisschen einfacher aber da müsstest du
den raspberry pi dort betreiben das was man eben weiß nicht also ich finde so ein esp32
deutlich sinniger als als den raspberry pi für den pool sensor
moin max wie gehts ja aktuell top programmieren ist learning but dying c++ ja das stimmt
dein ssh geht nicht wie kann ich mutti starten ja irgendwann musst du halt mal anfangen
irgendjemand hat immer mal zum einstieg keine erfahrung und wenn du nur sagst du gibst
immer nur leuten die chance die keine ahnung fünf jahre plus berufserfahrung haben wirst
du keinen nachwuchs bekommen
eine sekunde leute ich muss mal kurz die nass putze wie man so auf hessisch sagt
pinterest insta community okay ja ist ja gut ich glaube euch dass es da viele gibt
twitter war mal twitter war mal ruby on rails und github ist glaube ich immer noch ruby
ne keine ahnung gibt nix anderes
hast du mitbekommen was bei euch im bahnhofsfeld letzter zeit abgegangen ist nö ich war schon
eine weile nicht mehr in frankfurt jetzt geht lab geht lab ist auch rails ja aber github
auch so wir gucken jetzt bis in videos auf geht's wir lassen uns jetzt erstmal von level
cap jebaiten nein level cap jebait battlefield delays put franchise in trouble ja da habe
ich ja auch schon video zu gemacht egal levelcap erzähl uns ich muss mal den boomerang luschen
was stadia ist not dead stadia ist die ganze zeit schon not dead so so ein so ich würde
sagen stadia ist eher ein zombie aktuell ja da habe ich mich ja auch schon drüber ausgelassen
in dem video und mich drüber lustig gemacht was für ein reinfall das ist und wie unfähig
die leute sind was da ist und eins muss ich an der stelle jetzt auch noch mal sagen ich
war am anfang ja auch eher auf dem trip dass ich fast nur auf ea gebäscht habe dies was
dazu geführt hat aber ganz im ernst nachdem ich mir jetzt eine weile darüber gedanken
gemacht habe spiele kam ja im november raus muss ich sagen da ist war letztendlich dafür
verantwortlich wie die ganzen sachen implementiert werden und wie die ganzen sachen gemacht werden
im spiel also das ist mindestens mal 50 50 ea hat übertrieben mit es muss raus dieses
jahr aber da ist hat keine ahnung mehr wie man ordentliches battlefield macht und wenn
ich das schon sehe hässerzaun hässerzaun ist so die hülle der der quasi der entwurf
eines spielmodus ist das ist der wahnsinn dass das es überhaupt in das spiel geschafft
hat hat jemand länger als zwei runden hässerzaun gespielt wie kann man allen ernstes so einen
so einen praktizieren praktikanten arbeit eines spielmodus ist in ein fertiges game einbauen
roadmap was concise to put it one way but it did roughly outline what we should expect for
the games future the next significant patch to the game update 3.3 has been pushed back
to march this update is said to include numerous game features often considered to be the very
basics of any first person shooter update 3.3 brings with it a scoreboard voip a new player
profile page a more refined ping system as well as improvements to the reward im prinzip
wisst ihr was das was der mitz da dran ist die wollen uns allen ernstes erzählen es braucht
irgendwie ein halbes jahr um den scoreboard und voip und player statistiken einzubauen
jetzt mal ernsthaft warum braucht man ein halbes jahr dafür das kann doch nicht sein
die player statistiken sind eh schon im back-end gespeichert garantiert du musst die gui technisch
irgendwie anzeigen so super das würde ich das würden wir hier mit dem chat zusammen
in einer halben stunde machen wahrscheinlich na gut sagen wir in zwei stunden scoreboard
die statistiken hast du auch schon du musst ein scoreboard ingame bauen ok was weiß ich
brauchst du zwei tage für ich weiß ich was voip voip braucht vielleicht noch ein bisschen
länger aber es gibt so viele fertige p2p voip libraries mittlerweile und darüber wird
es ja letztendlich laufen die ich mal stark von aus es ist auch nix irgendwie halbes jahr
richtig ist keine ahnung was sie da machen das finde ich auch so geil das spiel ist jetzt
seit november raus und sie überlegen sich jetzt was man denn machen könnte irgendwann
irgendwo irgendwie aber man kann auch nicht drüber reden das ist der typische dice bullshit
gelaber was die letzten jahre über auch schon gegeben hat ja chat das ist eine gute frage
das frage ich mich nämlich auch ich verstehe nicht wie man wollte nicht einfach aus den
vorherigen spiel nutzen kann ich frage mich eh gerade bei battlefield 2042 frage ich mich
dass seit das das erste mal als ich der hand an das game legen durfte warum müssen die
immer bei komplett null anfangen ich meine die haben vorläufe an battlefield games die
können jetzt vielleicht nicht eins zu eins dort sachen importieren aber gewisse gewisse
logik die da drinne ist in dem spiel kannst du garantiert wiederverwenden und wenn du
sie nicht wiederverwenden kannst kannst du zumindest abgucken und abgucken ist halb programmiert
schon ist das die battlefield stats an den new world new world ist auch am abkacken müssen
wir sie eigentlich müssen wir eigentlich wöchentlich angucken das verstehe ich nicht
warum fangen die immer bei null an und es wirkt auch so als fangen die bei null an weil
es immer die gleichen sachen sind rum rumgelegge hittrack animationen die nicht richtig funktionieren
gadgets die nicht richtig funktionieren immer der gleiche scheiß warum fangen die immer
bei null an keine ahnung ich verstehe es nicht das game fühlt sich so an als hätten
die vorher noch nie ein battlefield entwickelt was wahrscheinlich auch so ist die leute die
da jetzt da sind haben wahrscheinlich vorher wirklich noch nie ein battlefield entwickelt
nein seh ich nicht so nein seh ich nicht so komm mal die
haben so ein riesen team an leuten das sollte doch wohl in der die sollten doch wohl in der
lage sein also wahrscheinlich haben sie jetzt kein riesen team mehr weil die a gesagt hat
wir ziehen euch alle ab wir lassen fünf leute an battlefield arbeiten der rest macht was
neues aber hätte man da wirklich ein ordentlich großes team dran gesetzt dann sollte es doch
ohne probleme möglich sein das spiel zu fixen plus neuen content zu bringen guckt euch apex
und guckt euch fortnite und sonstige sachen die bringen konstant patches und die bringen
konstant updates gut das spiel ist natürlich auch nicht so klasse fack wie battlefield
2042 aber ich meine die kochen doch auch alle nur mit wasser es muss doch möglich sein
ein spiel zu fixen und parallel an neuem content zu arbeiten wenn man die milliarden und und
entwickler ressourcen von ei hat wenn man denn will und meine schlussfolgung ist einfach
nur daraus man will nicht was mich wieder darin bestärkt in dem was ich eh schon vermutet
habe dass das game durch ist dass das game am ende ist und man nur noch das mindeste
macht und das mindeste bringt dass man seine versprechen nicht komplett bricht die müssen
vier seasons bringen weil sie haben vier seasons verkauft sie haben für sie versprochen
sie müssen vier seasons bringen und sie werden einfach vier minimals seasons bringen und
das game danach still unheimlich einstellen into a core experience that isn't working
as intended and as a means of compensation for these continued skins gibt ea and dice
are giving oh klapper klapper nice ich kriege skins in einem game dass ich nicht spielen
will dafür dass ich das was ich spielen will nicht bekomme ganz toll super fast legendary
bundle to all players of battlefield twenty forty two the bundle includes new skins for
mckay the k-thirty smg m-forty-four revolver and bolt alongside some other cosmetic items
this pack is a nice token but at the end of the day it is still just a cosmetic pack that
presumably would have been added to the store at some point anyway it'll be handed out to
players in early march another battlefield news the mobile game is being developed by
teams at industrial toy sieht das scheiße aus wenn ich schon wenn ich schon steuerung
sehe auf einem tap touch screen kriege ich kriege ich sprechreiz komplett davon ist
so meine güte die konfirmung wusstet ihr eigentlich dass battlefield 3 in mobile game hat hatte hatte
ob er kann sich kaum noch einer treten battlefield 3 hat ein mobile game guck mal
ne ne
nein nein nein nein nein das stimmt nicht
das war fake das war fake im ich glaube man findet ich glaube ich glaube man findet da
irgendwie gar nichts mehr ja das da genau das da
wahrscheinlich besserer saunen battlefield 2042
mobile steuerung an
mobile steuerung
wahrscheinlich ist das besser als das richtig echte battlefield 2 also das große battlefield 2042
hätte es controller support ist das grand bazaar ist das grand bazaar nur mit reskin das ist
bazaar guck mal hinten geht es zur flagge hier hinten hier rechts geht es in die hier oben ist
die brücke leute das ist doch bazaar was wir da im hintergrund sehen oder jaja klar ist das bazaar
was wir im hintergrund haben 100 pro hier hinten ist das born hier ist die brücke da jaja das ist
das ist grand bazaar bloß ein bisschen reskin das jetzt umgefallen ist klohäuschen liegt anstatt
zu contain toward the end of the month the mobile game is set to launch at some point this year so
another busy week is more details have emerged in relation to warzone in this year's new mainline
title activision blizzards investor call was canceled due to the recent microsoft acquisition
though many details were shared in the shareholders results statement the main point being that call
of duty 2022 development will be helmed by infinity ward studio which is the main studio behind some
of the franchises biggest hits most notably the 2019 iteration of modern warfare in a statement
activision blizzard stated that infinity ward infinity ward hat das spiel erfunden im endeffekt
sollte man vielleicht nicht vergessen allerdings sind halt davon kaum noch welche da meant on this
year's premium and warzone experiences it's unclear whether or not the current warzone teams
at raven software will continue to assist infinity ward or if they'll move on to a different project
activision blizzard is calling the next call of duty game the most ambitious plan in the franchise
industry leading innovation and a industry leading innovation was hat er eigentlich mit
seinen armen gemacht hier das sieht irgendwie ungesund aus appealing franchise setting of course
without more context these claims are well just claims at this point the rumor right now
zählen doch immer den gleichen will follow on from 2019 modern warfare and will follow the war on
drugs in south america is probably safe to assume that an official reveal is on the way considering
what has been said on the topic this past week warzone's latest game update dropped on february 3rd
and it reintroduced the classic loadout system from the original verdansk map the revert to the
loadout drops was made due to extreme community outcry that has been ongoing since the caldera map
shipped back in december players were unable to buy their loadout drops even if they had earned
enough in-game cash instead they were forced to wait a set amount of time until after the free
drop became available on the map many players felt as though this change greatly slowed down the
pace of the matches forcing them to use the ground loot instead of their preferred loadouts now
with this week's update when playing the standard battle royale modes loadouts can be purchased
from the get-go as soon as you've earned enough cash though this revert hasn't yet been applied to
the vanguard royale playlist rockstar games the studio behind the grand theft auto franchise put
out a news update detailing future content drops and improvements to gta online and at the end of
this article is a paragraph now that's what's next now that's that in entwicklung is oder man da
sich gedanken drüber macht das ist auch jetzt wirklich kein geheimnis das ist könnt ihr euch
noch dran erinnern wo vor ein paar jahren der elder scroll 6 trailer gezeigt wurde wo nix
anderes war als die schrift und das main theme fertig und da war auch noch allen klar natürlich
arbeiten die data natürlich machen sich gedanken darüber in this paragraph rocks are actually
states that they are pleased to confirm that the active development on the next entry in the
grand theft auto series is well underway and is that right now there's a little more than rumor to
coincide with this announcement apparently development was underway back in 2020 which
means that it's somewhat likely the game will ship in the mid 2020s maybe as soon as 2024 rock
star co-founder dan hauser who helped write many of the previous gta games as well as red dead
redemption bully and max pain 3 has since moved on so it'll be interesting to see how this new
era of rockstar games fairs google is apparently working to salvage their stadia technology
shipping it around the world to different partners under the name google stream some of these
partners include but we will end this einfach um und dann wird auch scheiße natürlich gold ganz
sicherlich google so wird das funktionieren an at&t bungee are rumored to be working on their own
streaming platform that will utilize the google stream tech while at&t are allowing customers
to stream arkham knight from their web browser erinnert ihr euch noch als stadia angekündigt
wurde wo sie dann auch ihre graßen pläne erzählt haben und sowas negative latency erinnert
sich noch einer dran negative negative verzögerung und sowas negative latency die haben so viel
bullshit erzählt und die welt ist ja damals komplett am rad gedreht und ein stadia und
streaming ist die zukunft und ich habe damals auch schon gesagt nein streaming wird nicht die
zukunft sein ich kann mir vorstellen dass es für manche leute eine alternative zum eigenen pc ist
oder zur eigenen konsole ist aber im großen und ganzen wird es das nicht sein und das war es auch
nicht und wird es auch in nächster zeit nicht werden in talks with google as they may use this
stadia streaming tech to allow players to stream demos of games through a specific website google
stadia famously failed to meet sales expectations and the project was shut down in february of last
year but in typical google fashion it seems like a lot of the reach bestes wurde wurde das shut down wirklich
habe ich gerade mitgekriegt search and development done for stadia may in fact show up again in the
form of this google stream service we'll just have to wait and see how it all turns out a new mobile
based warcraft game was briefly detailed in activision blizzard's financial statement on top
of the substantial new content for the warcraft franchise in 2022 statement a new mobile die
haben ja mit die haben ja mit diablo immortal so gute erfahrungen gemacht schon wie das angekommen
ist und da haben die sich jetzt gedacht oh ja das müssen wir unbedingt mit wollen wir warcraft auch
machen warcraft game will also put content into players hands for the first time and of course
this is just about as little information as you could give about the game so what sort of game
this will be is pretty much anybody was das ist ja was das lustige ist wenn man sich die grafik
aus heutigen maßstäben anguckt von world of warcraft das könnte durchaus ein mobile game sein aber
das ist ja glaube ich auch classic was wir hier sehen oder fans appreciate the fact that the
announcement was made subtly though back in 20 marks welchen wish robot empfiehlt zu gar
kein ich habe keinen am start aber wenn dann würde ich mir den kaufen der bei wallet wallet hudo auf
der empfehlungsliste steht das war glaube ich in den tremey z10 oder sowas wo ich mir kurz
überlegt habe ob ich mir den holen soll da nämlich auch eine reinigung also eine absaugstation und
sowas drin 18 blizzard went a completely different direction with the diablo immortal mobile game
and its announcement which left fans angry and upset thank you the mobile warcraft games announcement
wasn't shrouded in man das wird ohne problem als mobile game durchgehen a new optional update
for windows 11 users has just gone live that addresses bugs affect windows alda performance
for the past eight months users on the windows insider program have been testing out potential
grinses for this annoying bug that severely downgraded gaming performance on windows 11 pcs
thankfully the official patch has gone live and users are reporting much more stable performance
while gaming with the new os this patch alone may be enough incentive for some users to finally
switch over to windows 11 before we move on to robo rocks kann so nicht mehr flaschen den letzten
robo rock den du flaschen kannst ist der s5 den man sinnvoll flaschen kann in the comments what
exactly you hope to see from call of duty this year would you want to see ganz ehrlich ich ich habe
eher ein punkt den ich mir nicht wünsche von call of duty diese dieses jahr ich fand ja
diesen modern warfare reboot zwar aus finanzieller sicht irgendwie verständlich aber eine kreative
komplett bankrotterklärung nicht so dass call of duty die letzten jahre davor jetzt irgendwie mit
wahnsinns innovation und kreativität geklenzt hätte aber der modern warfare reboot war für mich der
absolute tiefpunkt gar nicht so sehr das game was am ende rausgekommen ist das lasse ich mir durchaus
gefallen aber allein modern warfare zu rebooten war kreativ aus kreativ was ich der absolute
tiefpunkt in call of duty erreicht hat und jetzt das ganze fortzusetzen quasi mit einem mb2 zehn
jahre später oder so irgendwie wieder wo sie im endeffekt jetzt ja quasi wirklich in die
regionen vordringen müssen die sie schon behandelt haben sie haben sich ja so gedreht am ende das
modern warfare 2019 quasi vor modern warfare 2009 oder wann das raus kam gespielt hat jetzt
müssen sie ja quasi also ich weiß nicht also ich finde das finde das sehr sehr unsinnig
mir wäre es lieber die machen was neues gescheites
rich single player store campaign a grittier multiplayer experience or are your eyes set on
the next phase of warzone and while you're at it make sure that you've subscribed to stay up to
date with the video und nicht vergessen dass ja wohl laut richten so wie ich das auf youtube
mit bekomme und back's in modern warfare 2019 dass ja wohl multiplayer technisch kaum noch spielbar
ist aktuell gaming news so nie boss jim ryan answer some very telling questions sony hat
übrigens bungee gekauft dass ich mitgekriegt hat week in regards to the future of the playstation
platform firstly rank and firm that playstation's 3.6 billion dollar buy guys bungee the creators
of it wasn't in response to microsoft's reason of duty naja was heißt spielst du noch ich spiele
ab und zu mal und ich habe mir die meisten auch gekauft also wenn gerade habe ich mir zum
beispiel nicht gekauft und was habe ich mir noch nicht gekauft ich ein paar habe ich mir nicht
gekauft aber ansonsten ab und zu klar should of activision blizzard instead the bungee deal
had been in the making for several months ryan also said that we should expect more studios
to be acquired leute leute anscheid anscheid ich habe eine frage frage alle chat wer ist
bestes anscheid grill chloe oder fuck wie ist die andere chloe nadine oder elena wer
ist bestes anscheid grill elena also chat ich tendiere auch zu elena
ich sehe da chatte sich auch nicht ganz einig
ja auf den anscheid film bin ich nicht wirklich gespannt da erwarte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
nicht so viel von so said that we should expect more studios to be acquired by sony in the near
future many have speculated that the playstation's acquisition of bungee may result in the studio
venturing beyond just gaming possibly through tv and movies not to mention bungee's impressive
portfolio of live service games such as destiny and how playstation can now adopt that formula
and apply it to other ips also eins muss ich sagen jim ryan commented on jedes mal wenn ich
anscheid muss ich sagen die leute die die animationen gemacht haben ich weiß ich ob man das
animationen nennen kann an sich es hat ja bestimmt auch was was weiß ich wie das in game umgesetzt
ist und wie das wie das reagiert wenn du auf an wende läuft dass also den fuß hoch macht so was
aber ich sag mal so dieses komplette bewegungs- und animationssystem von anscheid die leute das
gemacht haben die sind wirklich absolut massive IQ das ist glaube ich das beste was mir so was ich
je gespielt habe in dieser richtung immer noch immer noch also das ist echt absoluter wahnsinn
ihr müsst euch mal animationen angucken von anscheid es ist sogar es reicht wenn ihr euch das
aller allererste anscheid anguckt das ist ja immer noch besser als das was viele games heute
abliefern ist einfach wahnsinn das stimmt ihr habt ihr habt so recht es gab einen kurzfilm
den anscheid fern und anscheid fern kurzfilm mit diesem mit diesem typ hier ich kann nason
fillion ich weiß wie man richtig ausspricht der typ sieht original aus wie nason tracke
guckt euch den mann der dude sieht die költe alle das ist original mann ähnlicher kannst du dem
nicht sehen der sieht wenigstens so aus und ist ungefähr in dem alter wie er in den spielen ist
und mal ganz davon abgesehen was mich auch übelst gleich mal abgeschreckt hat ist dass
also sally sieht ja in dem film überhaupt nicht aus wie sally und sie zeigen ja auch wie sie sich
zum ersten mal treffen was ja überhaupt nicht den spielen entspricht egal also ich erwarte
da nicht so viel ich habe assassins creed war auch richtig gut in dieser richtung aber ich
habe die letzten assassins creed alle nicht mehr gespielt ja solche dinge also man muss sagen also
das haben die wirklich gut hinkriegen darf sie nicht vergessen anscheid 1 kam zu ps3 zeiten
raus damals wenn du mit charaktere gegen die wand gelaufen bist haben die in der regel einfach ihre
weit ihre wand ihre weiterlauf animation auch abgespielt und in anscheid 1 wenn du gegen die
wand gerannt bist haben sie schon solche sachen gemacht wie er stützt sich mit der hand ab er
macht so den fuß gegen die wand dass du nicht dagegen grenzt er rennt kurz gegen die wand und
prallt davon ab und so also viel viel besser aber animationstechnisch ist anscheid wirklich mega
mega geil anscheid 1 war auf der ps3 ja das ist wohl richtig ja vom alter her passt das und von
der optik ehrlich gesagt könnte ich mir den tatsächlich auch ganz gut vorstellen naja so
headset from sony but it does provide a nice summary of what i can do some of the highlights
include 4k hdr visuals groundbreaking new controllers haptic feedback i tracking and 3d
was auch was gehtts no launch date for the second generation vr headset a report from june
last year intuitively that it may ship holiday 2022 mich nicht so diesmal hat uns levelkaf gar
Gar nicht so sehr Chebade, der hat tatsächlich zu dem was gesagt, was er auch angekündigt hat, dass er was sagen wird. Sehr schön.
Chebade wird weniger.
Keine Ahnung.
War das nicht Tom, wollte ich gerade sagen, war das nicht Tom Cruise, der mit Scientology, aber ganz davon abgesehen, wäre mir jetzt auch ziemlich egal.
Solange die Filme was taugen, können die glaubenstechnisch machen, was sie wollen.
Wissen Sie, was ich bemerkenswert finde?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Scientology das ist, die erzählen, dass am Ende, wenn die Welt untergeht, die Aliens vorbeikommen und quasi die besten der besten mitnehmen.
Die besten der besten sind natürlich die, die genug gespendet haben, ist ja logisch.
Dann weiß ich, ob das Scientology ist, aber was ich witzig finde ist, wenn man sich so mal das Ende der Welt anguckt,
Wenn man sich so mal das Ende der Welt anguckt, was weiß ich, so was in der Bibel steht und
sonst was, dann ist lustigerweise das Ende der Welt, dass irgendwelche Aliens vorbeikommen
und hier landen, noch das realistischste von allen.
So bescheuert ist das mittlerweile schon.
Ich finde es so Kotlin, ja, gut, was ich bisher gesehen habe, es ist irgendwie eine
Mischung aus Java, C-Sharp und bisschen Ruby-Anleihen habe ich auch gesehen.
Also ich fand es, was ich bisher gesehen habe, nicht schlecht.
Warum hat sich eigentlich Bewegungssteuerung nie richtig durchgesetzt?
Ich glaube, weil die Leute gar keinen Bock haben, sich großartig zu bewegen, während
sie spielen.
Und das nächste ist, für die meisten Spiele ist es halt einfach direkter und angenehmer,
wenn du einfach eine Taste drückst, dass da was macht, anstatt dass du die Bewegung auch
wirklich machen musst.
Also gerade niemand könnte sich irgendwelche Multiplayer-Shooter mit Bewegungssteuerung
vorstellen.
Gibt ja die einen oder anderen Versuche, so etwas in VR zu machen, aber...
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
I built a big server rack for my home lab.
Aha.
Aha
Komm zahm zahm zahm
Trying out
Okay wir können daran anschließen was eben das
Wollen wir uns noch ein Stadia
Video geben
Trying out Google Stadia 2 years later
Wo wir dann einfach eine Runde
Cacken können
Wie schlecht es ist
Ja komm wir gucken uns eine Runde Google Stadia an
Stadia
Kack weh
Ja
Ja das habe ich mitgekriegt aber nicht das
Stadia geschlossen wurde
Die haben ja damals auch bald nur Skate
Auf Stadia angekündigt also
Als erstes den Trailer gezeigt
Davon und sowas
Und alle dachten sich
Boah die haben aber richtig was vor
Nope haben sie nicht
Ja zeig her
Ich habs abbestellt damals
Ich habs abbestellt
Ja okay komm mal zum Punkt
Ne den Chromecast
Musste man damals bestellen
Ich habs dann aber abbestellt
Weiß gar nicht mehr warum ich es abbestellt habe
Ich glaube sie ich glaube ich weiß wieder warum
Ich glaube ich habs abbestellt
Weil
Sie mir gesagt haben
Ich bekomme es nicht zum Releasetag
Obwohl ich es irgendwie zwei Monate vorher vorbestellt habe
Und dann habe ich mir gesagt Google ihr könnt mich mal
Pro Membership was kostet denn das Pro Membership Stadia
Du musst dich um diese fucking Seite anzeigen
Zu können einloggen wollen die mich verarschen
Nicht ernsthaft
Die leckt mich gucken wir uns net an
Damit will ich gar nicht weiter
Will ich gar nicht mich weiter mit
Beschäftigen
mehr alle. 500 Dollar Smart Home Setup. Also 500 Dollar
kommste eigentlich ganz gut mit hin. Das Problem bei ihm ist nur, dass der irgendwie
sich 500 verschiedene Apps installiert und das geil findet am Ende. Woop Rage. Ja, aber
das sehe ich nicht ein. Ich lock mich doch nicht ein, nur um mir die Preisliste anzeigen
lassen zu können, wenn man besten will. Also für 500 Euro. Okay Leute, ohne dass ich mir
das jetzt hier angucken würde, das meiste davon, irgendwelche komischen Hubs und so
würde ich mir eh nicht kaufen. Wisst ihr was ich machen würde von 500 Euro Smart Home Setup?
Also das erste was ich machen würde ist tatsächlich Fenster Windows Sensoren,
weil ich das sehr praktisch finde. Und wenn man das über AliExpress bestellt,
ist es auch relativ günstig. Also rein. Okay, okay, wir müssen noch einen Schritt zurückgehen.
Wir müssen noch einen Schritt zurückgehen. Es geht ja nicht nur um Sensoren. Wenn man neu anfängt,
dann muss man ja auch sich Gedanken drüber machen über den Server und Sticks und sowas
in der Richtung. Und da würde ich tatsächlich mich am Anfang über, würde ich mir tatsächlich
am Anfang überlegen, entscheide ich mich hauptsächlich für Z-Wave oder für Zigbee plus
Wi-Fi. Wi-Fi wird es ja immer dabei geben. Und das erste was ich von diesen 500 Euro tatsächlich
machen würde ist, in dem Fall gebe ich ihm recht, ich würde einen Raspberry Pi kaufen
und ein Konbi Stick. Weil theoretisch ist Z-Wave zwar kompatibler untereinander, aber das Zigbee
Zeug ist mittlerweile auch gut supportet und meistens günstiger als Z-Wave. Deswegen,
ich würde mir einen Raspberry Pi kaufen mit einem Konbi Stick. Ich würde Home Assistant
drauf installieren. Ich würde im Haus 4 bis 5 Zigbee Steckdosen verteilen bzw. Zigbee Geräte,
die das Mesh aufbauen. Dann würde ich mir Zigbee Door Windows Sensors kaufen, weil ich
finde das ist eines der praktischsten Sachen am Anfang. Und dann sind wir wahrscheinlich
so bei 200 Euro oder so jetzt schon. Und dann würde ich mir überlegen, was ist das was
mich stört? Was ist das was ich automatisieren will, was mir quasi das Leben leichter macht
und es daraufhin dann ausrichten. Ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht mit LED Beleuchtung anfangen.
Aber guck mal was er sagt. What's up? Du hastest den Toilettensitz hochzuheben? Na ja das ist
ganz einfach, da brauchst du gar keine Automatisierung dafür. Lass den Toilettensitz einfach hochgeklappt.
Chat? Jaja Sekunde ich muss ja Chat beantworten. Hast du Proxmox auf deinem Server im Einsatz?
Nein habe ich nicht. Auf der Home Assistant Homepage wird ein Package mit Zigbee Adapter
angeboten. Aha. Okay. Also ich habe aktuell ein Konbi Zwei Stick vollkommen in Ordnung,
aber ich habe auch kein offizielles Home Assistant Bild. Ich habe da mein 2 HE Server Kiste stehen.
Ja. Nein. Das ist wo ich umgebaut habe. Wo ist denn das Video zu meinem Server Schrank?
Ist das schon wieder so lange her? Boah so lange ist es. Ich habe aber ganz schön viele
Videos gemacht in letzter Zeit oder? So. Im letzten Jahr. Jaja Max ist gut. Ich habe
hier unten diese 2 HE Kiste. Hier unten den da. Diese 2 HE Kiste und da ist eine VM drauf
mit Home Assistant. Fertig. Reicht. Okay was hat er da für ein Ding? Was ist denn das?
Ist das auch ein Zigbee Stick oder was ist das hier? Okay allein schon dass der irgendwelche
Ring Geräte hat. Ring kommt mir nicht ins Haus. Shelley ist schon eher. Das ist ein Aquara
Sensor. Also Ring kommt mir nicht ins Haus. Hubs. Gar keine Hubs. Den Raspberry Pi mit
einem ordentlichen Stick. Fertig. Und schon gar nicht Smart Things. Ja. Warum? Warum ist
mein Smart Home more reliable wenn ich mir irgendeinen komischen Hub kaufe versus einen
Raspberry Pi mit einem Konbistick? Warum? Was für Magie macht der Hub anders? Nein.
Nein. Ganz bestimmt nicht. Kein Echo. Ja viel besser. Was zum Teufel? Wahrscheinlich
für Laien einfacher einzurichten sagt der Chat. Auf den ersten Blick schon. Aber nachdem
man sich eh früher oder später ein bisschen mit der Thematik beschäftigen muss, kommt
man gar nicht drum herum. Weil mit einem Hersteller und einer Sache kommt man wahrscheinlich nicht
aus. Ich finde es führt kein Weg vorbei wenn man das ordentlich machen will. Gerade ohne
viel China Chinesen Cloud. Ich finde es führt kein Weg dran vorbei zwischen einem eigenen,
es kann ja auch ein Raspberry Pi sein. Es muss ja gar nichts größeres sein. Zwischen
einem eigenen Raspberry Pi mit Z-Wave oder Zigbee Stick. Und dann halt dementsprechend
die passende Software drauf. Und das über die Software, wenn die dann mal drauf ist,
zu pairn oder über das Webinterface von einem fertigen Hub zu pairn die Geräte, das macht
eigentlich keinen Unterschied. Also ich verwende hier das da, für zum Beispiel Zigbee to MQTT
und das Webinterface sieht folgendermaßen aus. So. Und wenn du ein neues Gerät pairn
willst, klickst du hier oben auf Permit Join, drückst den Pairing Knopf an einem Gerät
und dann taucht es hier auf. Fertig. Also das ist jetzt nicht wirklich schwieriger als
es in einem fertigen Hub ist. Ne, mein Vater würde das auch nicht alleine schaffen, aber
mir geht es ja hier um Technik Interessierte. Ich würde wahrscheinlich dem auch weder einen
SmartSync Hub noch sonst was empfehlen. Ich finde das ist schon wichtig, dass das irgendjemand
macht, der ein bisschen Plan vor der Technik hat. Sonst hast du dann am Endeffekt wieder
dieses Geschiss, wie die Leute, die sich Weiß Cameras gekauft haben und denen ihr Stream
öffentlich über China-Chinesen-Surfer im Internet einsehbar war. So, was ist das?
Also seine Einlagen zwischendrin sind schon etwas cringe.
Aber man muss sagen, gerade der Aquara-Sensor, der hat nur eine Knopfzelle drin, sowas was
auch in die Fernbedienung kommt. Wobei, in die älteren Fernbedienungen, also die neuen,
die schwach sind, die umgedreht, was in die neueren Fernbedienungen kommt. Die älteren
haben ja gerne solche Batterien drin und das hält trotzdem 2-3 Jahre.
Nein, nein, nein, kein Echo. Echo kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Hat jemand von euch den Amazon Echo und findet das geil?
Nee.
Ja, beste. Die Dinger sind richtig gut. Wir haben ja letztens bei AliExpress geguckt.
Bei AliExpress bekommt ihr da quasi auch schon 10er-Packs für relativ wenig Geld. Hättet
ihr das vor einem Jahr gekauft für noch weniger Geld. Aber wisst ihr, was ich mich frage?
Kann man diese Dinger, ich habe hier direkt neben mir habe ich einen liegen, so ein Aquara-Sensor.
Meint ihr, man kann die Outdoor verwenden? Die haben ja erstmal nichts Offensichtliches,
was da Wasser rein kann, aber ich weiß nicht, wie dicht das ist. Ob die Outdoor überleben?
Ne Weile. Was macht das Ding überhaupt? Das ist ein Magnet, da ist ein Magnet drin und
da ist ein Re-Switch drin, der erkennt, ob der Magnet dran ist oder nicht. Und dann meldet
er einfach nur offen oder geschlossen. Das benutzt du zum Beispiel, um zu erkennen, ob
Fenster oder Türen auf und zu sind. Ich meine, selbst wenn der kaputt geht, das ist ja nicht
so viel Geld jetzt verschwendet. Du kriegst ja irgendwie für 7,9€. Ich habe mir überlegt,
ob ich nicht einfach Heißkleber drumherum mache. Ich zeige euch mal, mal gucken, ob man
hier ein ordentliches Bild. Aquara-Door-Sensor. Da gibt es bestimmt ein bisschen schönere,
nähere Aufnahmen. Blablabla. Nein, der labert einfach nur. Der labert auch einfach nur.
Kann mal irgendeiner dieses Ding zeigen? Ja, hier sieht man es ganz gut. Also bei dem Teil
kann ja nicht viel passieren. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein Magnet drin, sonst nix. Auf
der Seite. Mit dem Ding kann eigentlich nix passieren. Outdoor. Hier bin ich halt ein
bisschen skeptischer. Du hast einmal unten, das ist nicht wirklich ein Loch, das ist so
zum auseinander machen mit dem Fingernagel. Wenn ich hier einfach eine Runde Heißkleber
drum mache, sollte das doch eigentlich dicht sein. Oder ein bisschen Silikonband zum Beispiel
drum wickeln. Silikonband. Einfach einmal in Silikonband eingewickelt. Mach das Bild
in der Mitte mal auf, das da. Ja guck, hier ist nur ein Magnet drin. Hier ist nur ein
Magnet drin. Wie machst du dann den Akkuwechsel? Naja, entweder neuen Sensor hin oder ich mache
halt den Heißkleber wieder ab. Oder ich mache das Silikonband wieder runter. Ich glaube,
ich wickel da. Das ist ja wirklich klein das Zeug. Ich meine, man erkennt es jetzt hier
nicht richtig. Guckt euch das mal im Vergleich zu der Größe von seiner Hand an. Also die
Rollen sind nicht groß. Ich glaube, ich wickel da einfach Silikonband drum. Übrigens Silikonband
ist eben mega mega poggers. Amazon. Silikonband. Selbstklebend. Die Dinger sind richtig nice.
Das ist wasserdicht, hält Bomben fest und also kann ich nur jedem empfehlen sich ein
zwei Rollen Silikonband daheim hinzulegen. Richtig, richtig. Guck mal, gibt es sogar durchsichtig.
Ich glaube, ich probiere das einfach mal aus. Oder aufmachen und die Platine versiegeln.
Könnte man vielleicht auch machen. Wisst ihr was ich mache? Chat, ihr habt mich auf die
Idee gebracht. Wisst ihr was ich mache? Ich mache das auf und fülle das einfach mit Heißkleber
auf. Dann ist vorbei mit Wasser. Ich mache das Ding einfach komplett voll mit Heißkleber
und dann drücke ich es wieder zu. Denke, da wird eher die Batterie an Kälte sterben.
Zum Glück ist es bei uns in Deutschland hier nicht so kalt. Ich pumpt das einfach voll
mit Heißkleber. Fertig. Und dann dicht. Gut ist. Die Batterie kommt ja wahrscheinlich
eh hinten rein. Pumpt das einfach mit Heißkleber voll easy. Easy. So machen wir das. Also hier
seht ihr ja wie klein die sind. Keine Ahnung, da brauche ich eine Fünftelpatrone Heißkleber
oder Achselpatrone Heißkleber. Und was geht es hier zu aufwachen? Ein Kondom drum zu binden
ist auch keine schlechte Idee. Das würde wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut funktionieren.
Na ja, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Der Aquara Sensor ist eines
der billigsten und eines der besten. Achja, eben kam es ja die Frage, was ich von Meta
und sowas halte. Das ist ja Meta Thread und sonst was. Ganz ehrlich, ich blicke da noch
ein bisschen zu wenig durch. Was ich verstanden habe, ist, dass Meta wohl das Übergeordnete
ist und Zigbee wohl Teil von Meta. Also quasi Meta ist nicht Layer 2, sondern oben drüber.
Das Video habe ich 22 Minuten, das können wir uns jetzt nicht angucken. Meta ist das
oben drüber und es gibt verschiedene Übertragungstechnologien, über die du dann quasi Meta übertragen
kannst. Das könnte unter anderem Zigbee sein. Ganz ehrlich, ich lasse das mal auf mich zukommen,
mal gucken, wie das im Endeffekt ankommt. Weil mein Z-Wave Zeug funktioniert ja. Wisst
ihr jetzt nicht, warum ich das großartig austauschen soll. Ja, aber die sind kacke.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, die meisten richtig billigen LED-Lampen habe ich eher den Eierhoch,
die sind Müll. Gerade was die Helligkeit angeht. Deswegen habe ich zum größten Teil
die Liflex-Dinger, die sind zwar ein bisschen teurer, halten aber lang, sind ziemlich hell
und lassen sich auch über Home Assistant Wifi ohne Probleme steuern. Ja, das ist ja
genau das Problem. Der hat sich jetzt selbst schon beantwortet, dass er das hier, was er
am Anfang zeigt, eigentlich gar nicht will. Er will Home Assistant mit oder es kann auch
Open Hub oder sonst was sein. Der will den Raspberry Pi mit den passenden Sticks dran.
Der will eigentlich keinen Hub. Wozu, also wo ist der Sinn, fünf verschiedene Hubs zu
betreiben, dass man den Kram verwenden kann, anstatt einen Raspberry Pi mit den passenden
Sticks hinzustellen? Und dann alles über ein System? Okay, das ist das Problem, dass
es ein typisches Kokona-Ding ist. Sowas kriegst du in unsere Wände gar nicht rein. Das ist
ein typisches Ami-Ding. Kannst du nur in Holzwände reinschneiden.
Also wisst ihr, was ich machen würde? Anstatt, dass ich sowas da rumwurschtel, behalte ich
einfach meine alten Schalter und mache einen Shelly drunter. Und schon hast du das Beste
aus beiden Welten. Easy. Hier ist ein toter Aquara-Sensor. Okay, zeig mal her. Und der
ist, durch was ist der gestorben? Durch was ist der gestorben? Durch Outdoor-Wasserschaden
oder wie? Ha. Ja, mal schauen. Ich füll das Ding ohne Scheiß, ich füll das mit Heißkleber
auf. Die Batterie ist doch eh hinten. Ich muss mal gucken. Ich mach das mit Heißkleber
voll und dann ist gut. Das ist, glaub ich, kein unisoliertes Kabel. Ich weiß nicht,
was das ist, aber das ist kein unisoliertes Kabel. Das ist kein Kabel, was für was verwendet
wird. Das ist wahrscheinlich, ums durchzuziehen oder so. Keine Ahnung, was die Amis da bauen
wieder. Aber Kona Electronics ist eh so ein Ding. Wisst ihr, was ich auch machen könnte?
Wisst ihr, was ich auch machen könnte? Ich hab noch ne Tic-Tac-Packung. Ich könnte den
Aquara-Sensor einfach in ne Tic-Tac-Packung stecken. Und die zu machen. Nee, nee, Leute,
wisst ihr, was ich mache? Ich mach das, was ich am Anfang gesagt hab. Ich nehm Silikonband,
wickel das Silikonband um den Sensor drum und gut ist. Ich brauch ja hierfür, für die
Seite brauch ich nix. Hier ist eh nur ein Magnet drin, da kann ja nix großartig kaputt
gehen. Und auf die Seite, um die Seite, ich wickel einfach Silikonband drum. Fertig.
Dann ist das Ding dicht. Pupperschüsse. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen groß für so
ein Sensor. Kauf dir den Geco-Hybrid. Was für ein Ding. Geco-Hybrid-Pop. Was? Ah,
das ist so was, wo du stirbst, wenn du aus einer atmest oder was? Nee, da krieg ich
ja nicht mehr auf. Ich wickel das in Silik, ich mach da eine Runde Silikonband drum und
gut ist. Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich bei den Amis wohnen würde in nem Holzhaus, wo ich einfach
nur ne Säge bräuchte, um neue Schalter einzubauen, würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch prefieren,
aber bei mir krieg ich halt nicht so einfach neue Schalter in die Wand. Deswegen kommt
nen Shelly unter den Schalter und gut ist, du siehst es nicht, der Schalter funktioniert
genauso wie vorher und ich kann es über WLAN ein- und ausschalten. Also das beste aus
beiden Welten. Shelly ist super Geschichte in der Richtung. Vestasburg hat ein Fazit-Video
von mir. Man glaubt es nicht, Buttons sind tatsächlich eine sehr praktische Geschichte,
aber es gibt eine gute Alternative zu Buttons und das sind NFC-Tags. NFC-Tags sind überall
dort, wo man sein Handy mitnimmt, echt praktisch. Ich hab zum Beispiel aufm Klo, das hab ich
jetzt schon ein paar Mal erzählt, ich hab euch auch das Video zugezeigt, aber es sind
immer neue Leute dabei, ich hab an meinem Klopapierkorb im Klo hab ich ein NFC-Tag hängen
und wenn ich aufs Klo gehe und es mir kalt ist, halte ich mein Handy an den NFC-Tag und
dann triggert das eine Automation, die den Heizlüfter anmacht. Kannste auch ein Schrumpfschlauchkabel
drum machen? Ja könnte ich auch, aber dann ist es halt oben und unten offen. Das Silikonband
würde ich halt so drum wickeln, dass es einmal linksrum einmal rechtsrum.
Tja, deswegen, deswegen nicht irgendwelche komischen Hubs verwenden, sondern einfach
einen Raspberry Pi hinstellen oder eine Lowpower Intel x86 Hardware, die passenden Zigbee-Sticks,
die passenden Z-Wave-Sticks, in Zukunft wahrscheinlich die passenden Meta- und Thread-Sticks und
es funktioniert, dann muss man sich nicht mit diesem Scheiß rumschlagen, man braucht
keine komischen China-Chinesen-Apps aufm Smartphone, es funktioniert einfach. Sicher, dass es
nicht NFC statt NFTs sind. Ich hab doch NFC gesagt, oder hab ich NFC gesagt? Nee, ich
hab NFC gesagt.
Das kann man in der aktuellen Zeit wahrscheinlich nicht bringen, da hast du Recht.
Schaut euch das mal an, Leute. Chainlaw hat versucht, ein Wub-China-Emo zu machen. Das
kann man in der aktuellen Zeit nicht bringen. Das ist zu hart, das geht nicht. Das wird
wahrscheinlich direkt gebannt. China-Chinesen-Keks. Nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht nicht, Chainlaw.
Ich find's gut, ich find's gut, aber ich glaub, das macht der aktuelle Zeitkreis nicht mit,
wahrscheinlich wird das Emote nicht immer genehmigt.
Es sind halt alle mega empfindlich, was dieses Thema angeht. Ich find's auch teilweise
extrem übertrieben, wie es zur aktuellen Zeit so läuft. Es wird ja in alles irgendwas
hyperrassistisches reininterpretiert. Aber ich glaube, dieses Emote würde von Twitch
nicht mal genehmigt werden.
Was ist das? Das will ich haben. 8 Dollar für so einen Buttonsack, da muss ich gucken,
was das für ein Button ist. Solange du sagst, dass Taiwan kein eigenes Land ist, ist alles
gut. Sonst kommt, wie heißt der Xiping, nee, wie heißt der Xingming, nee, alter, wie heißt
der Typ nochmal, der China-Chinesen-Chef, Xi, irgendwas. Xingpi, Xingpi, wie auch immer,
er kommt da persönlich vorbei. Wo ist denn hier der Button? Button, Button, Button, Ikea
Button. Ist das der Button, den er hier zeigt? Nö. Was ist das denn für ein Button, den
er da zeigt? Ich find den, ich find das mega nice. Für 8 Dollar so ein Mini-Knopf. Was
hat er da? Was ist denn das? Was ist das für ein, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Das
ist der Ikea-Dimmer. Ah, Ikea-Dimmer-Button. Ach hier, guck mal da. Oh, das ist nice.
Das ist ein Button, ein Zigbee-Button für 7 Euro. Das find ich sehr gut. Das ist nice.
Very nice. Das kommt auch hier gleich auf die Liste. Gleich auf die Liste.
Ja, ich hab auch ein Konbi-2. Das wird gut funktionieren. Und so ab und zu sind so Buttons
gar nimmer schlecht. Ok, da empfiehlt er jetzt was, was ich nicht empfehlen würde. Der steht
total auf Ring-Doorbells und ich weiß nicht so genau warum. Ich hasse Ring. Geh mal weg.
Also, spätestens wenn mir meine fucking Tür-Klingel im Monats-Abo aufschwätzen will,
ist vorbei.
Eufy Anker, auch alles China-Zeug. Ich gebe zu, Eufy und Anker hört sich nicht nach
China-Chinesen-Zeug an, ist es aber. Es ist genauso China-Chinesen-Zeug wie alles andere
auch.
Hier sieht man es übrigens schön, dass die Ami-Steckdosen so nach Sad-Smiley aussehen.
Genau. Die sehen so traurig aus. Da kommen mir auch nur selbstgeflashte, Tasmota-geflashte
Sachen ins Haus.
Ja, deswegen einen Hub nehmen, einen eigenen Hub bauen mit, sagen wir, Homo-System,
einen Raspberry Pi und den passenden Sticks. Easy. Die ganzen Probleme, die er immer hat,
ist, weil er 5000 Apps und 5000 verschiedene Hubs verwendet.
Deswegen einfach gucken oder naja, es ist aktuell schwierig, aber ich hab's
halt so gemacht, als dieses ganze Tuya-China-Chinesen-ESP-Zeug noch Tasmota-flashbar war, ich hab mir
halt einen riesen Vorrat an Steckdosen hier gekauft. Ich hab hier bestimmt noch 20 Steckdosen
rumliegen, alle geflasht, die ich in Zukunft einbauen kann, wenn ich mal was brauch. Das
reicht erst mal eine Weile.
Nein, nein, nein. Garantiert kein Firestick. Kein Firestick. Kommt mir auch nicht ins Haus.
Ich hab nen Shield-TV dran. Ich find Android-TV nämlich mittlerweile wirklich eine ganz gute
Geschichte. Gerade mit Kodi drauf, wenn man noch klassisches Fernsehen gucken will, ist
okay. Plus die ganzen Apps. Ja, preis-leistungstechnisch sind die Amazon-Dinger gut. Ja, das stimmt
schon. Preis-leistungstechnisch kannste da nix sagen, aber ich hab keinen Bock auf Amazon-Werbung,
wobei ich davon ausgehe, dass man die Fire-TVs auch deploaten kann. Aber Shield-TV ist wirklich
nice. Ich hab das jetzt seit ein paar Jahren und ich will eigentlich gar nix anderes haben.
Aber wie gesagt, ich find Android-TV mittlerweile gar nicht so übel. Android-TV sind schlechter,
was ist denn die Alternative dazu? Sag mir mal ne sinnvolle Alternative zu Android-TV,
wo du auch ne offizielle Amazon-App, ne offizielle Netflix-App und sowas hast. Was gibt's denn?
Apple-TV. Da kannst du es dann aber wahrscheinlich mit Kodi und sonst was vergessen. Chromecast
ist okay. Also wenn jetzt einer ankommt und sagt, Android-TV ist doof, aber Chromecast
alleine bringt dir ja gar nix. Auf Chromecast hast du keine Netflix-App, keine Amazon-App,
sondern du kannst Sachen von irgendwo hin streamen. Es gibt nix anderes als Android-TV.
Das ist halt die Sache. Mir fällt nix anderes ein. Ich setz lieber auf TVs eigene Software,
was ja auch zum größten Teil mittlerweile Android-TV ist. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
was hast du für Alternativen? Du hast Dings hier, wie heißt das? Dieses Firefox Ding bei
dieses abgespeckte Firefox-OS bei ich weiß nicht welche Hersteller das hat. Dann hast
du wie heißt das? Dieses Low-Budget-Ding von Samsung, Tyson, Tyssen, Titsen oder so. LG
ist Firefox. Das ist alles Müll. Bei Android-TV und selbst bei Android-TV innerhalb des Fernsehs,
beispielsweise mein Sony-Fernseh hat standardmäßig ja auch Android-TV drauf, hast du das Problem,
dass du dann auch irgendwie zwei Jahre keine Updates mehr kriegst. Das Beste, was man machen
kann ist, meiner Meinung nach zumindest, den Fernseh als dummes Fernsehgerät zu verwenden
und über HDMI zu füttern mit dem, was man braucht. Und dementsprechend macht man sich
meinetwegen einen Firestick dran, wobei ich Firesticks nicht mag, oder einen Shield-TV
oder einen Roku oder sonst was. Das ist unter der Haube alles Android-TV, aber nicht im
Fernseh embeddet und eingebaut. Und ich habe auch die allererste oder ich glaube, ich habe
die zweite Generation, ich weiß es nicht, also das Ding, was nicht aussieht wie ein
Zigarettenanzünder. Also ich habe noch einen Shield-TV von vor ein paar Jahren, es gibt
immer noch Updates, gab erst letztens was Neues und in Kombination mit dem, was ich
in Kombination mit Kodi drauf, also ich habe Kodi drauf, rein für Fernsehgucken, ich habe
nebenbei eine TV-Hatend-Kiste stehen und da ist die Amazon-App drauf, die Netflix-App
drauf, YouTube und sonst was. Du hast das Beste aus allen Welten. Du kannst offiziell
über die offiziellen Android-TV-Apps gucken. Was ja problematisch ist, wenn du das eingebaute
verwendest vom Hersteller, wenn es das da nämlich nicht für gibt, dann hast du gelitten.
Also sprich, wenn YouTube sagt, okay, wir ändern mal unsere API-Versionierung oder nicht
API-Versionierung, wir ändern mal unsere API wieder und die Apps werden nicht mal updated
auf der Fernsehintegrierten Lösung, ist vorbei, kannst du kein YouTube mehr gucken. Und das
in Kombination, du hast die offizielle YouTube-App, du hast die offizielle Amazon-App, du hast
die offizielle Netflix-App plus, dass du dir theoretisch jede x-beliebige andere Android-Anwendung
sideloaden kannst, finde ich, ist Android-TV auf einem externen Gerät das mit Abstand
das beste was man machen kann. Theoretisch kannst du sogar die Stadia-App drauf machen.
Ich habe in der Tat keinen Smart Speaker und ich bin mir aktuell auch unschlüssig, wozu
ich einen Smart Speaker verwenden würde. Kann ich mir, auch das ist eine gute Frage
vom Chat, kann ich mir ein Android-TV bauen mit dem Raspberry Pi oder etwa? Nee, also
ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es einen in irgendeiner Art und Weise repackagedes
Android-TV für den Raspberry Pi gibt. Mein Android für den Raspberry Pi gibt es ja auch,
aber das wird dir von der Performance wahrscheinlich nicht viel Freude bereiten, gehe ich jetzt
einfach mal von aus, dass es nicht so schön ist. Ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, ich gehe
aber davon aus, ein selbstgebautes Android-TV mit einem Raspberry Pi ist eher suboptimal.
Das Gute an dem, richtig, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, hast recht, da habe ich jetzt
gar nicht dran gedacht. Aber allein schon die Hardware, die in dem Shield-TV drin ist, beispielsweise,
man kann es auch relativ klar sagen, das Shield-TV hat ähnliche Hardware drin wie die Nintendo
Switch. Also was, was darauf ausgelegt ist, eine Oberfläche ist jetzt vielleicht falsch,
doch jetzt nicht die allerbeschissenste Performance zu bieten. Klar kackt die Switch ab gegen
aktuell andere Konsolen, aber es geht ja ums Rendern, ums flüssige Rendern von einem
GUI, was man ordentlich auf dem Fernsehen bedienen kann. Shield-TV und Switch-Hardware
ist relativ ähnlich und die Bedienung ist ziemlich flüssig, das ist alles auch von
den Animationen schön weich und ich hatte davor einen Raspberry Pi 3 dran mit Kodi drauf
und das hat halt geruchelt. Du hast den Performance-Unterschied gemerkt, also auf dem Shield-TV ist das
alles sehr schön weich, du hast das Gefühl, es läuft permanent mit 60 FPS, auch wenn
du mal irgendwie Anwendungen switcht, alles schön weich, Kodi auf dem Pi konntest du
vergessen. Und das größte Problem mit dem Raspberry Pi ist, zum Selbstbauen, das ist
das, was Hüpfer sagt oder Haipfer, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es richtig ausspricht,
das ganze DRM-Geschiss, du kriegst das teilweise hin, aber nur mit sehr viel Hängen und Würgen,
du musst dir dann von Chrome irgendwelche Custom-Files DRM rüberkopieren mit die DRM-Sachen
machen, also du musst dir irgendwelche Chromium-DLLs rüberkopieren, dass du DRM-Sachen abspielen
kannst im Browser und du hast trotzdem nicht die schöne Bedienung, wie es beispielsweise
die Amazon oder Netflix-App sonst ermöglichen würde, also unterm Strich, ihr wisst, ich
bin immer dafür zu haben, Sachen selbst zu basteln, aber unterm Strich kann man sagen,
ich glaube die beste Entscheidung aktuell, wenn man was fürs Wohnzimmer sucht, ist, sich
eine Kiste zu nehmen mit Android-TV drauf, also Low-Budget ist dann wahrscheinlich ein
Fire-TV-Stick, auch wenn ich den überhaupt nicht mag, danach kommen diese ganzen Roku
und was es sonst noch alles gibt und ein bisschen teurer ist dann das Shield-TV, das mittlerweile
aussieht wie ein Zigaretten-Anzünder, ich weiß nicht warum, also ich hab das hier, ich
hab die Variante und da hast du dann wirklich alles, was du so brauchst, du hast alle Android-Apps,
die es so gibt und du hast auch noch die Möglichkeit irgendwelche APKs zu sideload und sonst was,
ja das ist, dafür ist es halt auch nice.
Achso, bei der Gelegenheit soll ich vielleicht noch erwähnen, ich hab mein, das ist ja vielleicht
nicht schlecht, weil man immer ein bisschen Disclaimer macht, ich mein auch wenn das jetzt
Werbung aus Überzeugung war, weil ich es wirklich gut finde und eine Weile verwende,
ich hab damals mein Shield-TV von Nvidia gestellt bekommen, ach das ist gestellt, überlassen
bekommen, ja, im Gegenzug, also es war damals, hab ich eine Grafikkarte und ein Shield-TV
bekommen, wenn ich unter der Auflage, ich mach ein YouTube-Video drüber, hab ich gemacht,
alles ist gut und ich muss jetzt vielleicht mal, nochmal erwähnen, ja.
PainLore, was ist denn los hier, spammer nicht so rum, mein Wohnzimmer Setup, genau, das
ist mein Wohnzimmer Setup, hier sieht man es ja, ja, das ist zwar von 2017, hier neben
sieht man irgendwo, hier sieht man das Shield-TV, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es Auflage
von Nvidia war, dass ich die Nvidia Ente mit im Video zeige, ich glaube nicht, aber ja,
so sieht es aus, das ist das alte Shield-TV und das hier, da ist Kodi im Fullscreen drauf
und nebenbei zeige ich halt hier noch was, so ein bisschen YouTube gedöhnt, so die ganzen
Apps, die es da drauf gegeben hat.
Das ist performanstechnisch, kann ich mich echt nicht beschweren, das bekommt sogar immer
noch Updates, das hat erst vor zwei Wochen oder so auf neue Android-Versionen geupdatet,
das ist richtig gut, wirklich nice, also hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Gibt es einen TV-Optimien-Youtube-Vertrag, gute Frage, weiß ich nicht, ich verwende
den offiziellen Client, weil ich habe YouTube Premium oder YouTube Red, wie heißt es denn
jetzt eigentlich, YouTube Premium, ich nenne es einfach mal Premium, aber ich habe mir
YouTube Premium nicht gekauft über den EU-Store, sondern ich habe YouTube Premium über ein
indisches Abo, da kostet es bloß 3 Euro oder so im Monat oder 2,90 irgendwie im Monat,
das ist viel billiger, ja, YouTube Premium Indien, ja, viel, viel billiger, nur 130
Rupien, 1,65 Euro, aber das kannst du mit dem ganz normalen Google-Account machen, du
kannst doch nach Argentinien, warum ist das Steuerhinterziehung, du machst ganz normale
Abrechnungen über dein Google-Account, das ist absolut in Ordnung, ja, also das kann
ich empfehlen, YouTube Premium über Indien abschließen.
Es könnte sein, dass es ein bisschen PayPal-Gebühren kostet, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber in
Anbelang der Tatsache, dass es 1,60 Euro versus 11 Euro oder so sind, ja, brauchst du dann
einen VPN oder so, dass es funktioniert, ja, aber ich mache das über eine indische VM
bei Digital Ocean, ich mache in Indien Bangalore, da haben die Rechenzentrums stehen, mache
ich eine VM, SSH-Tunnel mit Socks-Proxy und das ist quasi ein bisschen, sagen wir so,
es hat einen ähnlichen Effekt wie VPN, ich habe eine indische IP, ich gehe dann auf
YouTube Premium, logge mich ein mit meinem Account, also nicht mit MaxFPS, mit einem
anderen, Account logge ich mich ein, mache dann PayPal, man muss ein neues Payment-Profil,
man muss ein neues Payment-Profil abschließen, ein Anlegen sein im Account, dass es funktioniert.
Ne, du kannst es mit einer VM machen und Digital Ocean hättest du übrigens auch,
die rechnen ja minütlich oder stündlich ab, das heißt ich bezahle für die VM am Ende
irgendwie 5 Cent.
Ist auf jeden Fall zu empfehlen, ja, so, next.
Brauchst du eine aktive Indien-Verbindung, nein, braucht man nicht.
Alter, nein, keine Ring-Doorbell, hör mal auf.
Micky, danke für den Sub, fünf Monate, huge subscription, kannst du andere Doorbells empfehlen?
Nein, nicht wirklich, ich habe die Klingel, die in meinem Haus eingebaut ist, weiterverwendet
und habe eine Kamera zusätzlich hingehängt und ich bekomme mit, wenn die Klingel klingelt,
sodass ich die Kamera auf den Dashboards anzeigen kann.
Also ich habe quasi die Lösung, die im Haus eingebaut ist, verwende ich weiter plus eine
Kamera.
Ich würde dir den SmartThings Aotech Hub empfehlen, wenn du einen schnagst, wenn er
möglich ist.
Für diesen Setup, das ist ein Beispiel, was ich für etwa 500 Dollar bekommen würde.
Also wie gesagt, das ist das, was ich nur empfehle, also nicht dieses Setup, aber ich
kann es nur empfehlen, sich zu überlegen, was man machen will und dann Home Assistant
die passenden Sticks kaufen.
Irgendwelche fertigen Hubs, nein, ganz ehrlich, da würde ich nicht glücklich werden mit.
Das Video durch, Leute, ich muss mal kacken, aber ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt nicht auf,
wir gucken jetzt noch ein Video und ich glaube, dann gehe ich auf und mache mir auch mal Mittagessen.
Schauen wir mal, was können wir uns noch angucken?
Das wollte keiner wissen, ich habe es euch trotzdem mal mitgeteilt.
I build a big server rack for my Homelab, ja, zeig mal her, big server rack, yep, big rack,
yep rack.
Okay, wenigstens mal einer, der nicht mit dieser verkackten Dream Machine von Unifile
rumgeht, ordentliche Storage, warum haben die alle dieses komische Rack gefühlt,
damit hat jeder, der daheim einen Rack baut, dieses Ding, zumindest die Amis, hat er sich
wirklich IT-Profession über seinen Rack reingeschrieben, habe ich jetzt, ach hier oben, vielleicht
heißt sein Channel so, nö, ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht, aber was ich cool finde, er
hat Lärm, so Schalldinger für seine Aufnahme, das bringt bestimmt was, ganz wichtig, Leute,
Racks heutzutage, RGB-Beleuchtung, Server Racks ohne RGB-Beleuchtung ist heute nicht
mehr möglich, ich meine, wer will ja auch auf diesen Performance Boost verzichten?
Singlor, das wundert mich nicht, und dementsprechend, nachdem ich den Performance Boost ja auch
haben will, habe ich ja auch bei mir mittlerweile RGB drinne, ja, das sieht man ja hier, ich
zeige es euch ja hier am Ende, so, ja, wichtig, ich habe auch RGB in meinem Serverraum, ganz,
ganz wichtig, ohne RGB, kein Rack, richtig und wichtig, genau, oh, wie ich diese Redewendung
hasse, ey, aber in dem Fall trifft es zu richtig und wichtig, RGB im Server Rack, ich frage
mich eh, wie das bei uns im Rechenzentrum auf der Arbeit genau funktioniert ohne RGB,
auf der anderen Seite klar, deswegen haben wir auch die ganzen Probleme, letztens war
bei uns, ja, ich werde bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht auch mal erzählen, letztens war
bei uns irgendeine Glasfaserleitung im Rechenzentrum kaputt und sie wussten nicht welche und
haben irgendwie ewig einen halben Monat oder so rumprobiert, bis es jetzt gefunden haben,
in Wirklichkeit müssten die einfach anstatt normales Licht RGB-Licht verwenden und schon
wird es funktionieren, aber das sind halt so Boomer und Oldschool, die wissen einfach
nicht, dass RGB vorzuziehen ist.
Wann kommt eigentlich dein Home Assistant Video?
Da ist es doch, ach du meinst ein zusätzliches, wo ich mehr als das hier zeige, ja, da muss
ich die anderen Tabs noch ein bisschen anonymisieren, dass ich das zeigen kann.
Wie kann man nicht wissen, welche Kabel in mein Set kaputt ist, da ist doch auf jedem
Port ein Monitoring drauf, man sieht sich dort, ja, würde man von ausgehen, keine Ahnung,
ich kann es dir nicht sagen, keine Ahnung, ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass sie dann irgendwie
die Kabel getauscht haben und danach festgestellt haben, dass die Errors weg sind, wahrscheinlich
haben sie das so gemacht, wie du das gesagt hast, sie wussten es erst nicht, richtig,
haben dann Netzwerk seitlich irgendwie analysiert, Kabel getauscht, geguckt ob es daran liegt
und festgestellt, das Kabel ist kaputt, wahrscheinlich so in der Richtung, ja, ich habe damit nichts
zu tun, ich kriege das nur immer in irgendwelchen Weekly-Runden mit, wenn über sowas berichtet
wird, wahrscheinlich haben sie es so rausgekriegt.
Was ist das, TP-Link, TP-Link-Switch, null, kein, Leute, Leute, kein 10G, kein 10G in
Weirdchamp! Weirdchamp!
Cringe. Ja, Cringe kein 10G.
Weirdchamp. Er hat doch gesagt 10G. Achso!
Okay, dann ist es Pogchamp.
As I said, this is the first server rack that I've ever built at home and I've spent hours and hours of researching it and finding out what is the best way to do it.
Wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen ist, weil ich seinen Akzent gerade höre? Wisst ihr was ich lustig finde immer?
Dass eigentlich zu 99% Deutsche immer getriggert sind von Deutschen, die Englisch reden.
Englisch-Native-Speaker regt das überhaupt nicht auf. Die sagen halt, okay man hört das ist Deutscher, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich finde das immer lustig, wie die Leute sich darüber lustig machen, über Deutsche, die Englisch reden.
...split this into separate videos to show you exactly what I've done.
Dabei versteht man ihn doch wunderbar.
So this is only the first part. There will be at least three more videos about the different devices here.
Drei mehr.
But let's start at the beginning and show you the room where I've placed this server rack.
So this room you should be already very familiar with it, because this is the main room where...
Ich will das rack sehen.
...just work, shoot internet cables and the connection.
Oh jetzt wird gebaut.
So that was my plan.
Bau-Champ.
But let me also talk a little more about the different components.
Solange Baerbock mich redet, okay keine Ahnung, die habe ich glaube ich noch nie Englisch reden gehört.
Also am besten ist immer noch die Rede vom Oettinger gewesen.
In my home country Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat.
Das fand sogar ich ein wenig cringe.
Ich skippe mal ein bisschen vor bis das rack fällt.
Achja, übrigens, wenn ihr...
Nur mal so am Rande.
Also es funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Diese Mutte, weiß gar nicht wie man die nennt, die sind ja keine Muttern.
Klippse, klippst man hier rein und dann schraubt man das durch.
Und durch das reinschrauben drücken die sich noch ein bisschen weiter auseinander.
Und sitzen dann richtig fest, richtig fest im rack drin.
So und ich kann euch empfehlen, das nach Möglichkeit noch reinzuklipsen,
wenn das rack noch nicht in der letzten Ecke steht.
Weil man bricht sich damit auch ganz gerne mal, wenn man die versucht von vorne nach hinten reinzuklipsen.
Man bricht sich da auch mal ganz gerne den Fingernagel ab.
Oder klemmt sich den Finger ein bisschen ein oder sowas.
Also die Dinger sind gar nicht so ohne.
Ich hab ne Zange für sowas, das ist richtig.
Hab ich persönlich noch nie verwendet.
Und auch noch nicht mal zu meiner Zeit, wo ich die Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht hab.
Also wo ich die Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht hab.
Ich war ja täglich im Rechenzentrum und hab quasi täglich Sachen eingebaut mit solchen Dingern.
Da hab ich alles von Hand immer geklippst.
Aber der Vorteil davon ist, du kommst in einem ordentlichen Rechenzentrum an das rack von vorne und von hinten richtig dran.
Und oftmals, wenn man die Dinger daheim in eine Ecke stellt, kommt man von hinten halt nicht mehr so gut dran.
Dabei ist es, wenn man sich das mal genau überlegt, eigentlich sehr wichtig von hinten dran zu kommen.
Weil die ganzen Server ja absichtlich ihre Anschlüsse hinten haben.
Aber man hat halt daheim nur so viele Möglichkeiten, wie man halt Möglichkeiten hat.
Ja, das ist Müll.
Ja, Schienen sind tatsächlich sehr praktisch für Server.
Also du hast ja zwei Varianten.
Du kannst theoretisch den Server so fest vorne schrauben, dass er von alleine im Rack hängt.
Das funktioniert eigentlich bei nahezu allen, selbst bei richtig fetten Kisten, also die sind richtig massiv.
Aber natürlich hängen die dann ein bisschen hinten runter und es ist auf Dauer auch für die Schrauben nicht gut.
Deswegen, so eine Schiene hat durchaus seine Vorteile.
Und das Beste an so einer Schiene ist, du kannst die Server vorne rausziehen, ohne dass sie runterfallen.
Was für eine Stromrechnung bekommt man eigentlich, wenn man sich ein Rack hinstellt?
Das Rack allein braucht ja keinen Strom, ist die Frage, was du reinstellst.
Wenn du das Rack jetzt vollmachst mit fünf Playcentern, dann wirst du ordentlich viele Stromrechnungen haben.
Wenn du da nur Low-Power-Sachen reinhängst und ein bisschen Netzwerkequipment, dann wird sich nicht großartig auswirken.
Wobei fünf Playcenter schon ein bisschen schwierig ist in so was daheim.
Playcenter ist was? 8 HE oder so? Es wird schwierig in so einen Rack reinzukriegen.
Fünf Stück.
Okay, ich will eigentlich nur mal gucken, was er am Ende reinmacht.
Das Bauen ist jetzt nicht so super spannend.
Erst mal Sellout. Devices in my Rack. Okay, jetzt kommen die interessanten Sachen.
Ja, was hast du denn drin? Zeig mal her.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt kein 10G, habe ich doch gesagt, dass es kein 10G ist.
Wisst ihr, warum ich mir dachte, dass es kein 10G-Switch ist? Weil es so viele Ports hat.
10G-Switch mit 24, 24 10G-Ports Kupfer ist teuer.
Doch, doch, ich kann was re-recommenden.
Entweder den ES16XG Ubiquiti-Switch, der ist ziemlich gut, preisleistungsmäßig.
Oder Mikrotik-Switches.
Beste Pausenstelle, wo ich gerade angehalten habe.
Das ist nicht so teuer, das stimmt.
Aber weißt du was das Gute ist? Weißt du was das Witzige ist? Wenn ordentlicher, wenn er sich 100 Euro für diesen Switch ausgegeben hat,
für nicht viel mehr bekommst du den Mikrotik-Switch, Router-Switch, je nachdem, mit 2 10G-Ports und 1 Gigabit-Ports.
Also man kann zum Beispiel Mikrotik, CSS3, sowas da zum Beispiel nehmen.
Der hat, wie ihr hier seht, 24 1G-Ports und 2 10G-Ports und der ist gar nicht mal so viel teurer.
Ja, 126 Euro.
Ja, was gebrauchtes könnte man tatsächlich auch nehmen in dem Fall.
Da hast du schon recht.
Ich hab halt immer Bedenken, wenn die Dinger gar so alt sind, weil die halt mega, also so die, diese ganzen, diese,
wenn du dir bei Ebay irgend so ein altes Cisco-Ding kaufst, die brauchen halt, also sie machen Lärm ohne Ende und brauchen halt Strom ohne Ende.
Da hab ich immer ein bisschen Bedenken, aber wenn du dir was Gebrauchtes kaufst, was 2, 3 Jahre alt ist, dann ist das kein Problem.
Aber wenn du dir irgendwie so einen 10 Jahre alten Cisco-Switch kaufst, das Ding ist laut as fuck und braucht Strom as fuck.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wie verkabelt man denn die 10G- und die 1G-Ports?
Da gibt es eigentlich nichts Großartiges zu beachten, also in die 1G-Ports, also wenn du jetzt den hier meinst,
nehmen wir mal den hier als Beispiel, hier ganz normale RJ45-Kopferkabel rein und hier hast du dann halt die Option.
Hier hast du, das sind SFP-Plus-Ports, entweder machst du ein Glasfasermodul rein und machst da ein Glasfaserkabel
oder du machst ein Direct-Attach-Kabel, Kopfer ist das mit SFP-Modul, ist relativ günstig, kostet 20, 25, 30 Euro das Kabel,
geht aber nur bis maximal 10 Meter, aber das reicht ja in der Regel.
Oder du machst ein SFP-Plus auf RJ45-Modul rein und steckst ein ganz normales Kopferkabel rein, geht alles, kannst du dir aussuchen.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, rein von der Flexibilität her sind die SFP-Plus-Ports tatsächlich netter, aber verbreiteter ist natürlich hier der Kram.
Kannst du mir VLANs vs. Subnets erklären?
Wie kann man das schön und kurz und knackig sagen? VLANs sind Layer 2, also VLANs hast du irgendwie in deinem Ethernet-Frame hast du ein Header-Feld für VLAN-Tags.
VLANs kannst du dir im Prinzip wie unterschiedliche Switches vorstellen. Mit VLANs machst du quasi aus einem Switch mehrere Switches.
Und Subnets ist was eine Ebene weiter oben drüber.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so kurz und knackig erklären kann.
Aber VLANs ist was auf Layer 2, also sprich, wenn du jetzt einen Switch nimmst und stöpselst dort zwei Rechner dran und packst die in unterschiedliche Subnetze.
Da können die erstmal ohne den Router dazwischen nicht miteinander reden.
Aber sobald du den einen Rechner in das gleiche Subnetz packst wie den anderen, dann können die miteinander reden.
Packst du beide Rechner in unterschiedliche VLANs, dann können die auch nicht miteinander reden, selbst wenn sie im gleichen Subnetz sind.
Weil die Dinger nicht miteinander verbunden sind.
Schon eine Ebene weiter unten drunter.
Müssen die Module Originalhersteller sein? Nein. Die meisten Switche fressen mehr oder weniger alles, was es so gibt.
Cisco-Switches sind da tatsächlich noch am wählerischsten.
Ubiquiti hat sich da in den letzten Jahren auch nicht gerade mit Ruhm bekleckert, was Modulkompatibilität angeht.
Aber gerade die Mikrotik-Dinger, die fressen eigentlich nahezu alles an Modulen, was es gibt.
Ok, jetzt zeig mal her. Was ist drinne in dem Rack?
Aber wenn du nur ein paar Geräte verbinden willst, wie Printer, PC und so weiter, dann wird ein unmanagter Switch den Job machen.
Aber die Sache ist halt die, ich muss ja leider einhalten, aber wenn man halt für 30 Euro mehr einen managter Switch bekommt, mit zwei 10-Gigabit-Ports würde ich den trotzdem nehmen.
Ich habe auch einen einzigen kleinen PoE-Switch, weil ich gerade nur einen...
Subnet ist Layer 3, VLAN ist Layer 2, genau.
Wobei das ganze IP-technische Zeug so ein Hybrid ist aus Layer 2 und Layer 3, weil du musst dir mal sowas wie ARP angucken.
ARP ist nicht, also ARP brauchst du, dass IP funktioniert, aber ARP ist nicht wirklich Layer 3.
Das ist eher so Layer 2,5 oder sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen schwammig an der Stelle, aber prinzipiell kann man schon sagen, Subnet ist Layer 3 und VLAN ist Layer 2, genau.
Und das ist ein kleiner 5-Port PoE-Switch aus Netgear, es ist teuer, es ist unnetzbar.
Und wieder, es macht den Job. Ich denke, es kostet ca. 50 Euro und weil es nicht rechmmontiert ist, habe ich ihn nur auf eine Schale gesetzt.
Diese kleiner PoE-Switchen sind toll, um ein paar devices wie Wifi-Axispunkte oder Raspberry Pi aufzulegen.
Was ist sonst noch drin?
Okay, Proxmox am Start.
Also das Case erinnert mich jetzt an keinen speziellen Server-Hersteller.
Meint ihr, das ist was Fertiges gekauftes von...
Wobei, das ist nichts Fertiges gekauftes...
Ähm, Schwachsinn, das ist nichts Selbstgebautes, das ist was Fertiges gekauftes, was Selbstgebautes hat hier oben nicht dieses Ding zum Ausklappen.
Was ist das? Könnte das Lenovo sein? Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein bisschen blau. Hat jemand einen Plan, was das für ein Hersteller sein könnte?
Gerade hier oben, diese ausfahrbaren Panels hast du selten an Selbstbastelgehäusen.
Welche CPU mit Board empfiehlst du für kleine Home-Server, wo man Home-Assistence drauf machen will?
Naja, du kannst einfach einen Raspberry Pi nehmen.
Wenn dir das nicht reicht, dann würde ich irgendeine Low-Power-Intel-X86-Kiste nehmen.
Ist das vielleicht Free-It-So? Kein. Boah, da weiß ich gar nicht, wie die Dinger aussehen.
Wenn du mein Proxmox-Video siehst, ist das noch die gleiche Maschine. Ich habe sie einfach in einen Server-Rack-Kasten gelegt.
Okay, okay, er hat es, ja, okay. Hat er sich bei eBay ein Server-Gehäuse gekauft und hat das eingebaut? Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich schlaue Idee. Das ist fast billiger, sich ein gebrauchtes Server-Gehäuse bei eBay zu kaufen und es umzubauen, anstatt ein Server-Gehäuse neu zu kaufen.
Although this looks like a professional server machine, inside it is still more like a desktop PC than a server.
Es ist schon kein Problem. Es macht ja, mal ehrlich gesagt, es macht ja überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob jetzt in einem Server-Gehäuse Desktop-Hardware oder echte Server-Hardware ist und am Strich kommt es ja aufs Gleiche raus.
Das ist ja kein Unterschied in dem Sinn.
Du hast vielleicht bei Server-Hardware ein bisschen mehr Support für Enterprise-Zeug. Du hast da vielleicht ein SAS-Controller drauf oder ein SAS-RAID-Controller oder ECC-Unterstützung oder was auch immer, aber das brauchst du nicht.
Also der Software ist es doch scheißegal, ob das auf Desktop-Mainboard läuft oder auf einem echten Server. Das ist doch egal. Dementsprechend würde ich es genauso machen wie er.
Und du brauchst auch für daheim kein BMC oder wie hieß der Kram? RSA ist IBM, ILO ist Dell und nee, ILO ist HP und was ist Dell? iDRAC. iDRAC ist Dell, die Management-Controller.
iDRAC ist Dell, genau.
Könntest du ein Tutorial über MTLS machen? Nö, hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Und man braucht das nicht. Man braucht hier kein BMC. Ganz einfach, weil man in zwei Minuten an seinem Server-Rack daheim ist und nicht irgendwie wie in irgendeiner Firma von einem Gebäude ins andere laufen muss.
Das stimmt. Für günstige Server sind die Ryzen gar nicht übel, aber ich würde für Low-Power-Server, Low-Power und vielleicht jetzt nicht die wahnsinnskrasse Rechleise, würde ich immer noch Low-Power-Intel einbauen.
Also hab ich viele Leute gesehen, die Server-Racks und Home-Labs mit professionellen und teuren Server-Equipmenten bauen, aber für meine Home-Lab ist das nur eine perfekte und kost-effiziente Lösung, um es auf Desktop-Hardware zu bauen. Ich habe diese Kasse von Intratec gekauft, die eine deutsche Firma ist und sie produzieren viele PC-Kassen für Desktop-PCs und auch Server-Racks und Storage-Kassen.
Niko, BTC ist Bitcoin. Das ist wieder was ganz anderes. BMC ist ein Base... Was ist denn BMC eigentlich? Baseboard Management Controller? Also das kann ich an der Stelle... Muss ich das vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was ich hier überhaupt von mir gebe? Vielleicht geht es hier... BMC.
Also du hast ja oftmals das Problem, du hast ein Rechenzentrum und hast da einen Server stehen. Wie installierst du diesen Server? Also du musst ja irgendwie, wie man das auch von sich aus beim Rechner von daheim kennt, du musst ja irgendwie mal ins BIOS, die Bootreihenfolge umstellen, einen Linux Image mounten, um Linux zu installieren.
Also wie greifst du auf den Server zu, wenn er noch nicht installiert ist? Oder wie greifst du auf den Server zu, wenn er kaputt ist? Und dazu haben die meisten Systeme, die halt für professionelle Umgebung gedacht sind, haben noch einen zweiten Mini-PC quasi.
Das ist kein PC, das ist irgendein fertiger, fertiger Komplettlösungs-Chip. Aber sag mal, du hast auf einem normalen Server-Board hast du quasi nochmal einen ganz kleinen Mini-Server mit drauf, wo du dich dann, auch mit extra Netzwerkport meistens, wo du dich dann per Browser drauf connecten kannst und das dann ist, wie als würdest du direkt am Server mit Monitor und Tastatur sitzen. Also du kannst dann quasi da drüber ins BIOS vom Server, du kannst da drüber ins Boot-Menü und solche Sachen.
Und das bezeichnet man in der Regel als BMC. IPME geht wieder in die ähnliche Richtung. Da kannst du dann noch Sachen drüber setzen und abfragen. Bitcoin ist wieder was anderes.
Und iDRAC ist beispielsweise das BMC von Dell. ELO ist das BMC von HP und RSA2 ist das BMC von IBM oder Lenovo.
Genau, Baseboard Management Controller, heißt es glaube ich. Bin mir gar nicht sicher, was BMC heißt. Baseboard, nicht Basel, Baseboard Management Controller, genau.
Ist ein spezialisierter Mikrocontroller, der auf der Hauptplatine vieler Computer-Systeme, Inspiration und Servern eingebettet ist. Aha.
Wisst ihr, die wissen Bescheid. Wikipedia hat Ahnung.
Das ist, dass du deinen Server steuern kannst, so als würdest du davor sitzen, ohne dass du davor sitzt.
Hey, hey, guck mal, da ist mein Gehäuse. Das Gehäuse habe ich mir damals auch gekauft, weil es einfach nur weil es billig war. Das habe ich bei mir auch verstanden. Einfach nur weil es billig war.
Qualitativ, es wirkt schon ein bisschen billig, muss ich sagen, aber es funktioniert gut.
Okay, was hat er denn sonst noch eingebaut in seinem Rack? Aha, hier.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen was advancederes, davon habe ich keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sowas im Heimbereich wirklich braucht und ich stelle mir das sehr teuer vor, wenn man das neu kauft.
Jemand Erfahrung mit diesen Dingern? Ja gut, das ist wahrscheinlich quiet, weil es nicht viel zu tun hat.
Hier sieht man übrigens das schöne Vergnügen, Server-Hardware einbauen zu dürfen, ohne Schienen im Rack.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, das ist nicht ein 1 HE Switch, der im Endeffekt relativ wenig wiegt, sondern stellt euch mal vor, ihr baut ein 8 HE Playcenter so ein.
Kannst du vergessen, kannst du komplett knicken. Ich habe damals mit dem Felix zusammen, mit dem kennt ihr vielleicht noch aus ein paar älteren Videos, mit dem habe ich zusammen auch die Ausbildung gemacht, wo wir noch beim Provider beide gearbeitet haben.
Es ist wirklich nicht ohne. Wir haben damals zu zweit Playcenter eingebaut und die haben dich teilweise geklemmt und musstest du rausziehen aus den Schienen. Leute, ich sage euch, wenn da so ein 50-60 Kilo Ding im Rack hängt und nicht das macht, was du willst, das ist für den Durchschnitts-IT-Arm doch belastend.
Was einer Zubi von euch hat sich letztens an der Rechtschiene die ganze Hand auf Aua.
Aber was hat er denn sonst noch? Wie das was? Wer ist da denn drin? Achso, doch, jetzt habe ich ihm unrecht getan, doch, da ist er einiges drin. Der hat ja seine Proxmox Server drin. Okay, da ist schon ein bisschen was drin.
Was man damit daheim macht, gut, wäre die nächste Frage. Aber ist ein schönes Bild, kann man nicht sagen, auch viel Platz noch für die Zukunft zum Erweitern. Ich hätte anstatt der Hardware hier drin wahrscheinlich mir MikroTik-Switcher reingehängt, aber das ist bestimmt mit Sicherheit Geschmackssache. Es ist ein schönes Bild, was er gemacht hat.
Der Schicker fragt, ich bin jetzt nicht so technikbegabt, aber ist es rein technisch möglich, ein großes PC-Gehäuse zu kaufen und da nass HDDs einzubauen plus drei Grafikkarten? Geht um Platzmangel im Büro und eine Server-Lösung als 3D-Artist oder in dem Fall noch lieber einen Server. Das geht? Klar, natürlich geht das. Ich meine, du musst dir überlegen, die können ja auch nicht zaubern.
Also ob du da jetzt was in den Gehäuse einbaust, ob du das in den Server-Rack einbaust, im Prinzip ist das alles schlicht und ergreifend kein großer Unterschied. Du musst natürlich erst mal drei Grafikkarten aktuell bekommen, das ist schon richtig. Das dürfte wahrscheinlich das größere Problem sein, aktuell drei ordentliche Grafikkarten zu bekommen, wenn du nicht 10.000 Euro ausgeben willst.
Ja, aber du kannst das ohne Probleme in den Tower einbauen, du brauchst halt das passende Mainboard dafür und das passende Gehäuse, aber wenn du dir irgendeinen, also ganz im Ernst, ich habe hier die Fractal Design R5 und R6, ne R4 und R5, was auch immer, habe ich hier rumstehen und die Gehäuse sind schon relativ geräumig
und dahinten könnte ich auch, hätte ich ein Mainboard, hätte ich ein Mainboard mit drei gut angebundenen PCI Express Plätzen, könnte ich da ohne Probleme drei Grafikkarten einbauen.
Es sei denn, es ist Grafikkarten mit irgendwie vierfach Höhe oder so, würde funktionieren, also du findest garantiert was, jetzt nicht unbedingt das, gibt es vielleicht noch was besseres, kannst du machen, kannst das ohne Probleme in ein normales Tower Gehäuse einbauen und ja, du kannst dort auch dir einen Wechselrahmen kaufen und vorne, also baust dir vorne einen Wechselrahmen ein in dein Gehäuse und da kannst du sogar Hotswap machen mit deinen
Festplatten. Das funktioniert überhaupt kein Problem und wahrscheinlich ist es sogar günstiger am Ende, das in ein normales großes Tower Gehäuse einzubauen, als sich dort in irgendein Server Gehäuse und Rack zu bauen.
Ok, das schwierigste aktuell dürfte tatsächlich sein, an drei Grafikkarten zu kommen.
Also preistechnisch ist es auf jeden Fall sinnvoller es in Gehäuse zu bauen. Wozu sollte man zu Hause überhaupt einen Rack haben? Na weil es eine platzsparende Möglichkeit ist unter 19 Zoll Hardware einzubauen.
Brauchst du nicht, du kannst auch einfach dein Zeug alles auf den Boden stellen. Es ist nicht wirklich notwendig, das ist eher eine Frage von Platz und Platzeffizienz und Handhabung.
Du kannst ja auch einfach ein Mainboard auf den Teppich legen, das funktioniert auch. Ein Mainboard auf den Teppich legen und dann drei USB Festplatten anstöpseln oder drei SATA Platten anstöpseln.
Da kannst du sogar Hotswap machen direkt am SATA Port. Ob es dann funktioniert ist wieder was anderes.
Du kannst auch den Ikea Rack bauen. Also es ist alles eine Frage der Ästhetik, der Effizienz vom Platz her, letztendlich aber natürlich auch von der Geräusch und Temperaturentwicklung.
Du brauchst das nicht. Wie gesagt, du könntest ja auch einfach in eine Ecke hier deines Büros drei Mainboards auf den Boden legen und einen Switch daneben stellen. Das geht alles.
Best Large Capacity Do-It-Yourself NAS Option
Warum habe ich heute so viel Selbstbastelkram? Egal, das gucken wir uns auch noch an. Sechs Minuten passt schon.
40 Terabyte Do-It-Yourself TrueNAS Bild. Okay, ich kenne mich, da habe ich bestimmt einiges zu meckern dran. Allein schon, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass TrueNAS bzw. ZFS für den meisten daheim nicht unbedingt die beste Wahl ist. Egal, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Das Problem habe ich nicht. Höchstens mit Warzone.
Aber da bringt dir der NAS auch nichts, weil du dein Spiel bestimmt nicht über NAS laufen lassen willst. Okay, wo geht das Bild los? Wo wird gebildet?
Alter, das ist ein NAS Bild von sechs Minuten, der fängt erst mal nach was? Nach drei Minuten an mit dem NAS Bild? What the fuck? Ah hier, hier geht es los.
Wenn du... Nein, habe ich keinen Bedarf. Habe ich keinen Bedarf für... Wenn du Bedarf hast, könnte ich dir den Stellplatz in Hetzner Colocation in FS1 anbieten. Nein, habe ich keinen Bedarf für...
Und ich habe ja mittlerweile dank meinem Hetzner Placement, was ich gemacht habe, etwas direkteren Draht zu dehnen. Wenn ich das mal benötigen sollte, würde ich es wahrscheinlich über den Weg machen.
Aber danke der Nachfrage habe ich aber kein Bedürfnis, nee. So, weiter geht's. So, jetzt wird gebildet. Epic.
Huge Epic Montage. Jetzt kriegen wir schon Epic Montages auf NAS Builds. Ganz schön staubig. Epic Montage. Eigentlich fehlt... Ich wollte gerade sagen, es fehlt noch ein bisschen Dubstep.
Ja, geht schon los. Aber, aber RGB RAM. RGB RAM, wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob es RGB RAM ist. RGB Lüfter. RGB Lüfter ist natürlich für so eine NAS Build absolut essential.
Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop. Woop
halbe miete.
Der ist nicht völlig, Leute man sieht halt seinen bauch in einer sagen wir mal sehr ungünstigen
pose.
Ihr müsst den mich mal sehen wenn ich sowas zusammenbaue.
Da haben wir richtig pepo fett angesagt.
Epic montage ok ich gebe zu die montage könnte epischer sein.
Max ist heimlich dass er auspackt mmo spieler nicht alles liegen leute ich habe die motion
capturing dafür gemacht in wirklichkeit vor 15 jahren oder was anders rausgekommen ist
vor 15 jahren war ich alles andere als pepo fett vor 15 jahren war ich huge sportlich
rgb lüfter gib uns epic montage leute ok was sehe ich da lass mal kurz überlegen
was sehe ich da 015 netzteil hoffentlich hotswap fähigen wechselrahmen irgendein msi mainboard
dann sie das hier oben dürfte die grafikkarte sein vermute ich jetzt mal und das da unten
ist eine extra netzwerkarte kann das sein kann das sein dass er da eine extra netzwerkarte
eingebaut hat ne gpu im nass ahja das mainboard hat wahrscheinlich nix on board aber das daneben
sieht schon irgendwie hart nach einem vga anschluss aus oder sowas da sind noch mehr
sata ports dran gut dann hätte ich aber ein mainboard genommen mit ordentlich vielen sata
ports wir werden es ja wahrscheinlich gleich sehen was drinnen ist ok epic montage fertig
da ist es das ist eine grafikkarte und richtige oldschool grafikkarte dvi hdmi vga und das da
unten ist nichts dann doch für extra sata ports ja self hosted stadia der razor sticker leute
wenn ihr wüsstet was das ding noch für ein boost bringt durch den razor sticker wie wärs
denn wenn er uns erzählt was drinnen ist vielleicht hat er das vorher gemacht vor der epic montage
und ich habs übersprungen übersprungen ok das video war jetzt nicht so nicht so erhältlich
er hat doch nicht mal eine verlinkung was da unten drin war ok ne das ist vielleicht
auch nicht so sinnvoll gewesen jetzt ne der video beschreibung ist ja auch nix echt die
haben keinen quicksync wirklich nicht das erinnert was du meinst ist diese cx bla bla
bla serie ne wenn ich jetzt erwarte dass sie das erst recht haben playstation 3 emulation
auf dem pc ist seriously impressive ok ist es das big new features in node.js oh nein
node.js kriegt neue features für noch mehr java script in allen lebenslagen ok was sind
die neuesten optik ich blick bei meinen tabs nicht mehr durch leute ja genau den meine ich
den den hüpfer den meine ich hier ich blick mir bis zu viel den meine ich nicht nicht
cxc irgendwas genau die dinger meinte ich ja also hast du eigentlich ein lieblings linux
distribution arch ich benutze arch by the way und jetzt kommen die leute die mir sagen
ich darf nicht sagen arch by the way weil arch by the way nur für echte arch linux distribution
ist und ich verwende ja manjaro und manjaro ist kein richtiges arch deswegen darf ich nicht
arch by the way sagen verstanden so big new features in node ok nochmal chat noch eine
frage wenn man in die richtung devops engineer gehen will sollte man eine ahnung von server
hardware und so haben nicht zwangsläufig aber ganz im ernst nachdem ja quasi devops engineer
ich weiß damit werde ich vielleicht jetzt einige ärgern aber sagen wir mal so dass
server admin unserer zeit ist ein bisschen ahnung von server hardware ist nicht verkehrt
das heißt nicht linux sondern genug linux moment leute let me wo ist das genau ich wollte
gerade sagen wo ist die copypasta hinter checkform das muss das ist wichtig ja es ist genug linux
ok big new node features welche oberfläche bei manjaro i3 wm und am ende sieht das ganze
dann so aus poggers vm starten am ende sieht das ganze dann so aus ich starte jetzt einfach
mal linux vm du hast mal einen talk von stellman besucht ok ja der typ ist wild ja das stimmt
der ist pepo fett nicht der typ von vorher aus dem video ja guckt so sieht so sieht im
endeffekt meine oberfläche aus erster desktop firefox zweiter desktop terminal fertig wurde
der nicht gecancelt keine ahnung wegen was wegen was sollte stellman denn gecancelt werden
was hat er denn verbrochen ich meine der keller hat in der vergangenheit sicherlich da werden
er teilweise sachen ausgebuddelt die 30 jahre alt sind der hat bestimmt in den letzten 30
jahren die ein oder anderen aussagen getätigt die heute nicht gut ankommen könne ich mir
schon vorstellen bestimmt das würde zu dem passen dass er durchaus die ein oder anderen
kontroversen sachen gesagt hat so zumindest ich habe browser auf dem ersten bildschirm
terminal auf dem zweiten bildschirm und dann was ich brauche je nachdem auf dritten und
vierten bildschirm meistens die kombination backends backends zeugs hier auf dem dritten
bildschirm und wenn sich irgendwann mal startet ja backend auf dem dritten und hier visual
studio code für frontend geschichten auf dem vierten desktop und da dann halt noch
in chrome chrome offen um mir die seite im warum immer der chrome jetzt nicht aufgeht
lag grad ein bisschen genau so sieht das meistens bei mir aus browser terminal plus zeug was
da drin ist backend kram und hier frontend krams aus ist also gucken wir uns mal an was
note js neues hat
wohl war ich meine jetzt wo ich hier npm sehe was haben wir npm jahn pnpm es fängt ja schon
an bei package manager wurde 20 verschiedene hast der neueste schrei ist pnpm anscheinend
ist
Man kann jetzt direkt ordentlich HTTP-Requests in Node machen, ja wo kommen wir denn dahin?
Man darf ernsthaft ordentlich HTTP-Requests in Node machen, ich glaub's ja nicht. Wo kommen wir denn dahin,
wenn du für ein simples Node-Programm nicht mehr 40 GB Node-Modules brauchst? Das ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr JavaScript-Meme-gerecht.
Nein, nein. Also wir haben in dem Stream hier über die letzten Jahre einige Sachen schon selbst kompiliert.
Aber ich glaube Node.js war noch nie dabei und ich verspüre auch nicht den kleinsten Drang dazu, Node.js mal selbst zu kompilieren.
Ich habe mal versucht, Chrome selbst zu kompilieren und nachdem das Ding irgendwann 40 GB RAM gebraucht hat, habe ich es eingelassen.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Was? Ist das irgendein Pulli-Fill oder sowas, wo die JavaScript-Leute ja drauf stehen?
Also quasi so ein temporäres Ding, bis Fetch wirklich in Node drin ist oder wie? Das ist ein ganz normales Fetch.
Warum haben die eigentlich bei Node irgendwie acht Jahre oder so gebraucht? Keine Ahnung, Fetch im Browser kam wann?
Acht Jahre kommt doch ungefähr hin, oder? Warum haben die acht Jahre gebraucht, das in Node einzubauen? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Haben die gesagt, wir wollen an der Standard Library nichts machen und benutzt NPM Packages?
Warum ist das nicht erlaubt?
Eine Zug? Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Leute, ich mache mir jetzt was zu essen. Ich habe Hunger und der beste Moment aufzuhören ist, wenn man 420 Zuschauer hat.
Vor 20 Zuschauer besser geht es ja gar nicht. Guck mal schnell, ob irgendwie einer online ist, den ich hausten kann, der es braucht von der Größe her.
Der Zug ist abgefahren. Ja Hüpfer, das war der Microsoft-Bot. Kann ich mich auch daran erinnern.
Alter, Monka Corona. Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern. Wir sehen uns, bis dann. Macht's gut. Vielleicht stream ich heute Abend eine Runde Dark. Mal gucken.
Ich weiß, es wird nicht so viele interessieren, aber ich bin eher im Kreisel kreiten. Bisschen PVP-Action. Bis dann, macht's gut, CU.